in a new
poll from echelon insights republicans
were asked
what is or how would you rate these
issues
the most concerning issue among
republicans was illegal immigration and
that's fairly typical we've that's
that's been a big talking point for
republicans going back
decades so i'm not surprised there when
democrats were asked the same question
their biggest concern was trump
supporters
that's new that's creepy
that's actually really scary but it
makes sense when you think about some of
the data we've gone through on this show
before such as
the new york times data showing the
democrats have fired off far to the left
while republicans have kind of stayed
where they are
or similar data from pew research which
has been highlighted by tons of
organizations including us here at tim
cast irl as well as prageru
that shows that the median republican
has moved slightly to the right
and the median democrat has fired off
super far to the left
so when you ask a republican what are
your concerns they say yeah same thing
as always illegal immigration right
and when you ask a democrat they say the
trump supporters and as you know
what 95 percent of republicans supported
donald trump or 90 to 95 it's probably
gone down a bit
but this is democrats saying for the
most part the other
the republican the reason this is so
worrying is we recently heard msnbc
one of the msnbc hosts say uh why don't
we drone strike some of these people
we saw an article from the root which
according to newswhip
in 2018 was the most engaged with
leftist news source
where they said it's time to treat
republicans like enemy combatants
and if these people were in any and any
other country we would have droned them
that's kind of rhetoric that's coming i
got to tell you man it's getting scary
now we got the fbi investigating members
of congress
over what happened at the capitol
seizing congressional phone records
some some people are saying it's a
violation of the co-equal branches of
government executive branch going after
members of congress
apparently nancy plus is okay with it so
we're going to talk all about this stuff
today we are joined by journalist and
marine reservist julio rosas how's it
going man
you want to briefly just give us a
really quick introduction yeah no so i'm
currently in the marine corps reserves
uh part part-time and so my main job is
i'm a senior writer at townhall.com
cover all sorts of stuff riots have been
kind of the mainstay and then in between
that
immigration whole media bias yeah you
were recently down at the border i guess
yeah tijuana on friday yeah wow and
you've also covered tons of
stuff i've seen a ton of your videos i
think people have even like some of
these
guys have threatened you oh yeah oh yeah
of course you're interested
yeah right on cool we also got luke he's
hanging out so i forgot to mention this
but last week i wasn't here friday
because of a family matter
but i was looking at the comments and
there was one guy saying no luke
i puke and he was spamming that in there
and
that made my day and i want to say thank
you guys i really enjoy
engaging with you hi i'm an independent
journalist that does independent media
productions
on the youtube channel we are change i
also have a backup channel called look
we are change i'm not posting on there
but i will be doing some quirky weird
stuff on there so check out luke we are
change
subscribe if you're not subscribed and
even if you are subscribed
check it out because i'm i'm having a
lot of people contact me saying that
they're unsubscribed without them doing
it themselves so we are changed luke we
are changed thanks so much for having me
on
what's up everybody ian crossland
resident alien coming at you live
saying hey right on and i'm sour
patchlets pushing buttons in the corner
as i do
ladies and gentlemen before we get
started i am excited to announce we have
a sponsor today
this is biotrust multi-collagen ageless
go to stronger bones and life and you
can get 51
off of this collagen supplement i got i
got to be honest with everybody
i am i am 34 and i skate all the time
and that is ancient
in skateboarder timelines i recently
was skating i like i broke my i broke my
wrist i swear i broke my wrist i think i
did
well maybe i didn't but it was really
messed up now my elbow got all messed up
and i'm just like i gotta start taking
care of myself and so i'm really excited
we have this stuff we love
mixing this collagen supplement into our
drinks if you're not familiar collagen
is what makes up
your ligaments it makes you know
stronger skin and all that stuff
according to the biotrust website they
say
it makes your skin healthy and supple
gives you a youthful look
makes hair healthy and young looking i
don't have any of that so you know i
don't have to worry about that
supports joint flexibility strengthen
nails teeth and gums promote strong
healthy muscles
tendons and ligaments promotes stronger
bones supports digestive health
promotes healthy appetite management
again stronger bones in life.com
and i mean it i don't like promoting
things unless i actually feel good about
them
and they actually do something good for
me and uh
i am ancient in the world of
skateboarding i gotta i gotta also say
tony hawk to 720 and he's like 54 so
that that dude is is is a master but i
got some talking points for you because
i'm really so
there's a really cool stuff that they're
doing first of all you got a 60-day
money
60-day money day 60-day money-back
guarantee
this stuff is non-gmo it's free of
artificial colors flavors preservatives
sweeteners
there's it's free of gluten antibiotics
and rbgh and rbst
no odor no taste unlike bone broth or
other collagen supplements
no clumping free shipment on every order
and there's something really cool
for every order today they will donate a
nutritious meal to a hungry child in
your honor
through their partnership with no kid
hungry.org to date biotrust has provided
over 4.4 million meals to hungry kids
so please help biotrust hit their goal
of 5 million meals this year
dude i'm just going to say it one more
time i used to take
i i took nothing seriously in regards to
health i would skate i would eat junk
food
when i was late teens i'd be drinking
and i i regret it i do i don't really
drink all that much anymore i try to be
more serious about this stuff
but i got to tell you most of you
probably know you hit 30 and you're like
what am i doing
you better start taking it seriously
because next thing you know you're going
to be like struggling to get up the
stairs
i recently had like we had some a crew
come over for doing electrical work
and i'm running jumping up the stairs
full speed and sprinting and they're
like how do you do that
well i have ageless multi-collagen uh so
check it out
stronger bones and life.com seriously
thank you so much
to any sponsor uh because they're great
and don't forget to go to timcast.com
become a member because we have
exclusive i can find where the mouse is
at we have exclusive members only post
we did an hour the other day with mike
cernovich talking about the epstein
files
the containment of truth and what really
happened this is crazy stuff
so that's up at timcast.com don't forget
to like share subscribe let's jump in
to the first story so we have this post
from
kristen soltis anderson she says thread
on the new echelon insights polling
about voter priorities and what
republicans in particular are looking
for
unlike traditional top issues questions
here we ask people to rate each issue on
how much it concerns them
we tested these issues with everyone
let's just jump straight
well let's start with republicans first
i want because i want to build up to it
right
you know what the title of the segment
is you know we're talking about so let
me just show you
the kind of i guess regular opinions
of conservatives gop most concerned
about police support and illegal
immigration the question was
how concerned are you if at all that the
following are a problem for the country
the top was illegal immigration 59
were extremely concerned next lack of
support for the police
59 i'm sorry i'm sorry it's 79
extremely concerned high taxes 77
extremely concerned these are like
fairly typical republican things
i'm concerned about taxes and people
don't like the police and i wave my flag
and illegal immigrants
they talk about liberal bias in
mainstream media sean hannity and and
tucker carlson have been ranting on
liberal bias in the media forever and so
is glenn beck that's totally normal
there's not a whole lot that's new in
this socialism of course socialism
anti-for violence
well that's relatively new but you know
left-wing violence still isn't
something that exists and then you have
abortion tech censorship discrimination
against christians
i swear you could do the same poll 20
years ago and find the same answers
what do you think the democrats said the
most concerning thing with 82 percent
was donald trump's supporters followed
by
white nationalism 79 percent followed by
systemic racism at 77 percent and then
gun violence and then health care
then domestic terror then police
brutality you'll see a lot of these same
issues that you know democrats have
typically been concerned about
but i think it's particularly worrying
that at a time when we're seeing some of
the most
insane rhetoric pointed at republicans
and trump supporters
saying drones strike them saying treat
them as enemies and combatants
you don't see the same thing from
republicans so i'll ju before we throw
it to the to
everybody into this bigger conversation
i'll just point this out when i do my
segments on this show on
on my other channels and i say i'm not
look i may be biased
but i really do see the problem as being
on the democrat side of things not
republican
this is another data point that backs
that up republicans once again concerned
about the things they've always been
concerned about what am i going to
complain about
republicans saying the same thing they
said for 30 years sure i got criticisms
the democrats coming out and saying
trump supporters are the are the biggest
threat
that's scary luke you brought up last
week when that lady from msnbc said
why don't we just drone strike them we
drone-strike people in afghanistan
yeah i think it's fair to say that our
language is becoming a little bit
hyperbolic to say the least especially
politically i for sure
thought the the top thing on that list
was going to be masculinity
uh weights trucks and other inanimate
objects that people are scared of and
refuse to take personal responsibility
firearms defensive tools you know if
you're going to put guns there you got
to put forks on there because forks are
responsible for a lot of obesity a lot
of death and a lot of
horrible horrible sicknesses that we
need to be very responsible for by
banning the tools that enable
people to die of heart disease on such
huge numbers 300 000 people died in 2019
of obesity
exactly that's that's what like uh
almost a 911 every single day yeah
where's the non-stop
24 7 news coverage of people stuffing
mcdonald's down their food and talking
about how horrible it is and showing
them in the hospitals
goblets yeah down their throats
whatever you know you know what i'm
trying to say here uh but
but again there's a lot of bigger issues
out there and
i don't know i don't like polls i always
question the results of polls you could
manipulate polls in so many different
ways
uh so i i don't know i don't trust this
because this proves that the mainstream
media brainwashing is working because
again when you look at relative threats
to you it's usually a lot of the stuff
that a lot of elites are responsible for
that they don't want you to know about
we as we were talking about obesity
cancer
uh you know and other health-related
illnesses that of course are never truly
addressed but now again we have a care
and government that allegedly cares
about our health and is willing to stop
the economy and destroy everything in
its doorsteps just to make us healthy
yeah well sure you know luke and i have
definitely covered our share of riots
and and of various factions and uh and
julio you've been on the ground for ton
of this stuff
do you think that is it is fair for
democrats to say or or do you think it's
fair for them to be
most more concerned about trump
supporters than any other problem in the
country does that make sense
no it doesn't it's just i i would
completely disagree with with that
i think it should even be on the list i
think i know what you're going to say
that's why i'm asking i'm giving you the
obvious questions well it's just i mean
obviously i i think one of the factors
just
because what happened on january 6 i was
there i covered it uh and
but really i mean they what we saw most
of
last year and what what i covered from
kenosha to minneapolis and seattle
those were all done by left wing well
but kyle redenhaus
well that well that was well that was
born out of a situation
that was the result of the local and
state government not getting a handle on
riots that were again started by
left-wing and blm sympathizers and and
and standing down
yes yeah so this is the point i always i
keep making people are like tim all your
videos are about the democrats and i'm
like listen
when when has there been uh a moment
where a bunch of trump supporters
started smashing windows breaking into a
building
and you know being over all around
disruptive january 6.
can you tell me a time before that cause
i'm sure they exist you know but
any anything on top of your head like
something trump supporters came out
flags
marching through the street chanting and
smashing windows starting fires or
anything like that
and that number no not not that i can
recall nothing you know so
what i've seen is leftist violence and
extremism
and even then with all of the news
coverage
look at look at andy noe's book you guys
andy no put out that book on antifa
it's like a new york times bestseller
and republicans are still like yeah we
get antifa is a problem but
illegal immigration is more concerning
because there's a lot of policy
ramifications to illegal immigration
economic ramifications
so republicans right where they've
always been antifa going on doing their
thing republicans know it but they're
not screaming about like it's the end of
the world
some are for sure their concerns are
more practical policy
policy-driven democrats are pointing at
republicans so this is what
what is is worrying to me check out let
me let me show this article from the
root
they say democrats are stuck with a
republican party rife with conspiracy
theorists
anarchists and terror sympathizers the
craziest thing about this let me just
try and uh pull up the most
the most insane look at this they say we
have to view the gop
as enemy combatants because for years
they have proven
that democrats are theirs republicans
might view
democrats as like political rivals who
they don't like and will call names
but republicans aren't that concerned
about general democrats this is the
crazy thing about this echelon insights
thing
on the list of things republicans are
concerned about biden supporters is not
one of them
they they don't care about what people
who vote for joe biden
they care about problems the democrats
literally care about republicans
i shouldn't even say republicans because
the republican party is trash but
conservatives trump supporters trump
supporters are not republicans there's a
there's a big difference but there is an
overlap i guess
i can i can say you know republicans are
trash and most people be like you mean
the politicians right yeah oh of course
like everybody agrees so i'm worried
about this rhetoric man
i'm worried about this we also have this
article i'll pull this one up from 5 38.
in america's uncivil war republicans are
the aggressors
oh dude they live in in in a paranoid
delusional state
would you agree with that uh republicans
are the aggressors in the in the uncivil
war
as as a whole no i mean it's it's just
again
what what i what i covered and what what
i saw firsthand it wasn't people
in maga hats it wasn't people waving
trump flags
it was it was people that were
definitely aligned with more of the
radical elements of the left but i mean
antifa
as as as real as they are right
uh they weren't everywhere in terms in
terms of all the rights they weren't
responsible for every single one
obviously they had a hand obviously in
places like portland seattle where there
were the other strongholds but really it
was everyday people
especially especially when it started
out on day one because
then i can say in kenosha there were
antifa types
that came from chicago in milwaukee but
that was day three that was day two that
wasn't the first so
everything kind of went bad in that town
was everyday people quote you know
did you see did you guys see what
happened in new york where there was
like
an suv with trump flags yeah and then
regular
new yorker leftists started attacking it
and some women like pepper sprayed the
family including some children
oh when they had that little caravan no
no i don't think it was a it might have
been a little caravan i don't think it
was like a big parade i think it was
just
uh like suvs driving on the on on the
what was it the what's that what's the
highway
is that what it is the bqe the brooklyn
queens expressway and so
you've got these people are not antifa
these leftists
and that's crazy to me that you can have
these videos that republicans
conservatives trump supporters can see a
video of children being pepper sprayed
and still say
that's not my biggest concern whereas on
the left you get
one day where where trump supporters act
to fool
and that's the biggest concern they have
i think i think
it's it's the fake news the manipulation
it's going to lead to something
dramatically worse
my concern is as they kind of escalate
this and i'll just throw this this this
next bit in because i covered this the
other day that the fbi is treating
members of congress
they say uh they're treating members
members of congress has suspects
in the the capital riot what happens
when you have this rhetoric
where the democrats think this is their
biggest threat you're gonna get
politicians on the democrat side
who say vote for me and i will destroy
republicans
vote for me and i will come for them and
i will arrest them and we will lock them
up
and the trump supporters are like can i
get someone to deal with the immigration
issue
if the democrats see that the biggest
issue among their voter block
is trump supporters they will use all
the power they have to target them
that's what they've been doing right and
it's probably creating like a downward
spiral where it's going to keep getting
worse
and that's why that's why they have
concerns about establishing a 911 style
commission was like well how truly
neutral and independent is it going to
be when you have
people on their side saying that all 74
million trump
trump supporters are equal to three or
four hundred or so that is the capital
which is tsds we all supported
arrangements
we also have to understand the larger
kind of media conditioning that has been
going on
within the last four years that that
really was ratcheted up to levels that i
haven't ever seen it before
i always knew and talked about the
divide and conquer agenda for about 15
years now
but really the last four years were
absolutely insane if you look at
left-wing media
they're always saying right-wing terror
right-wingers are going to kill you
right-wingers are horrible and then and
just non-stop
24 7 coverage and then there's also some
criticism on right-wing coverage where
they said antiphon's responsible for
everything bad underneath the sun
and sometimes they were also exaggerated
sometimes they're also downplayed by the
left-wing media but we have to
understand this cycle
is spinning out of control and when the
democrats are in power right now
there are a legitimate amount of people
asking what do you got for us and the
first thing they got is
we could punish more trump supporters
and uh according to this poll that's
allegedly what they want and again i
find it hard to believe to be honest
with you because you don't like the poll
it's it's i have to really i i want to
deep
i want to deep dive into it to see
exactly how it was done to see exactly
how the questions were because i bet
we're gonna find some anomalies
because there's no way people who are
suffering so much
people who have been screwed over by the
establishment who have been promised
two thousand dollars and they're getting
nothing but military industrial complex
no bid contracts for raytheon right now
uh their two thousand dollars is out the
door there's no way that that their
first thing is
retribution i don't know you're wrong
that's my disagreement that's okay
you have your opinion i have mine that's
my own personal perspective because
seeing the responses yes there's a lot
of hyperbolic stuff on social media but
in in reality there's a lot of people
saying okay democrats you're
you're in charge what do you got for me
what can you do for me i i
i'm seeing people defend joe biden
setting up child
migrant detention facilities okay so
there was the one in homestead which is
the miami facility
kamala harris literally protested there
yep and all the democrats
not the progressives all of like the
establishment tribalists are going like
yay kamala
and then trump shut it down and they go
good it's about time trump
and then biden's administration reopened
it and they're like well actually you
know
it does make sense that biden is doing
this you see what they do so i i
disagree
i think you're right that there are
regular americans who are like yo
where's my money
bro you said i get two thousand dollars
where it where it's at
and and you're not getting it but i
think too many
and and it makes sense i mean like what
80 80 some odd percent
are just like trump is bad so there's
two things when the media for years kept
screaming at the top of their lungs
orange man bad
some people just ate that up and now
they're shaking in their homes terrified
of trump supporters but i think people
are realizing trump's not in
power the fbi is on top of all the
grannies that walked into the capitol
that day
there's no evil grannies that are going
to come after them and walk into their
private residency by accident
so so i think people are realizing that
and there's also very interesting
pushback with the
the gravel institute and aoc pushing
back against biden and this new kind of
uh you know what what what are they
calling now they're not trying to child
migrant overflow
overflow which are literally using
storage containers to put which has
which have bars on the windows
these facilities need to exist
separating families is awful
yeah but a lot of the separation occurs
because they don't know who the families
are yeah because it's some random guy
with a kid
and then the other issue is the facility
that biden opened up it's unaccompanied
kids
so like when a kid crosses the board and
they pick him up they're like what do we
do
we're not going to put them in an adult
jail with a bunch of old dudes
they put them in a facility a juvenile
facility yeah and
but like just like for me for me
personally because i am of you know
mexican descent the thing that just
really
irritates me is sure aoc
did a tweet saying yeah it's bad in any
administration but she's not going to go
down there
and do another do another phone call and
and and
just i remember uh just the complete
outrage at
the child separation policy which was
you know the outrage at it was
good i didn't agree with it at all uh
but
and then it just but it went beyond that
and then talk about kids in cages and
and
they were put they were putting photos
that were taken to your obama
administration yeah
and saying that oh and so basically
by and large the the mainstream media
and democrats view
latinos as uh as a hammer to beat
republicans with when it suits them and
so it's just
i i really see i'm just i'm really
upset at how they're you know if you're
going to be if you're going to be as
outraged as you were
when trump was in office then you should
be equally as outraged oh i just
realized
you're you're you're actually a mexican
yourself so i i don't i don't
i i'm i'm uh special in that i don't see
these things that the democrats
i'm killing but colorblind totally
colorful another thing to really kind of
uh let's be blunt here about is
especially when it comes to new
immigrants that come into this country
who do they serve they usually go to big
cities and they
serve a lot of these establishment
limousine
liberals and they're working in
under-appreciated underpaid
jobs usually under the table uh in a
position that that's predominantly
helps them yeah it exploits human beings
to the worst
degree for the benefit of the people
living in the cities who lives in the
cities predominantly liberals benefiting
off of it here's the point i was going
to make with that is that we recently
saw especially in south texas the latino
community went
for trump all the boy like a lot of the
board of countries in miami a district
that was
considered safe democrat flipped
republican
because it seems like this first of all
this idea that latinos in this country
are
one political body is just not not true
and you could probably speak this better
than i could yeah
but i know people i lived in miami i
know people who are from cuba and
venezuela and they're like nah
like they were staunch capitalists hated
those systems that you know they view as
destroying their country
but when you look at you know what's
going on these facilities i'm really
curious about who aoc is actually
speaking to when it's like ah in south
texas they're actually kind of pro-trump
you know
they've gone pretty hard for the
republicans i can't imagine they're
going to
disagree with the same policies that
trump had right well it's just
it's just the fact that they live at the
you know they live there in terms of in
terms of the border and so they they are
acutely aware of the issues that that
are plaguing the
immigration system and obviously just
the overall problems that we have this
at the southern border
and so i mean and that's why you see a
lot of uh border patrol
uh officers they're latino but i think
the majority of the officers are latino
because they often
come from those communities because
again they they see the importance
of border security they they know that
you just can't have
just it be open and what have you so
yeah i think it really i think the last
election obviously didn't go trump's way
but the fact that he was able to
gain a lot within the latino community
and other minorities as well but
especially the latino community i mean
you'd think that
you know after four years of talking
about how trump was just gonna
go after all the latinos and and you
know it's just this really bad dictator
right and then he's pretty pretty he's
pretty bad at being a dictator in that
in that regard if
the people that he's supposed to be
victimizing is actually going for him
the worst thing he did was post that
taco bowl it was like how dare you you
know it's like cultural appropriates
like taco balls aren't even actually
mexican or whatever
and and that looked good objectively it
looked good to me
i like taco balls yeah i don't know why
the image that just came to my head and
it's very
visceral is this kind of you know
this this kind of liberal sitting in a
fancy restaurant tweeting that we need
more immigration as they're of course at
a very fancy restaurant and behind the
doors are all the illegal immigrants
working their butts off
you know serving them and to me just
just
seeing that kind of representation just
kind of angers me to be honest with you
one of my favorite tweets in early in
the trump ministry i think it was 2018.
it was from this actress i forgot
who who it was but it was it was in los
angeles and she tweeted out that
oh there's immigration checkpoints and
so she's tweeting to her fellows
tell your gardeners to tell your
housemate tell them to avoid this area
and ever just like wait why are you just
why are you go why are you automatically
assuming that to tell there but but it's
true because that is that is a majority
of their set and so when they think
about
immigrants it's oh it's my it's the help
yeah exactly and it's just it's just
it's just so patronizing and it's just
so fake and i'm tired of it yeah yeah so
so
i i just i just pulled up the article
because i had to make sure i had it
kelly
she said if you kick out latinos who's
going to be cleaning your toilet
what these people again they just see us
as a political
tool to hit republicans with and to
clean their toilets and because they're
here
i'm going to read this quote and i'm
going to be very precise
and annoying how i read this for
political purposes because they're going
to call us out of context
kelly osborne said if you kick every
latino out of this country
then who is and this is this is what uh
cali osborne said
going to be cleaning your toilet donald
trump you know what i mean
osborne said in an attempt to call out
the republican presidential candidate
who faced massive backlash no that's not
no interrupted co-host rosie perez
continuing there's more jobs than that
in the country for latinos and latinos
are not the only people who clean
toilets
and she immediately backtracked i didn't
mean it like that come on i would never
mean it like that
dude you totally meant it like that and
it was only when she got snapback she
was like oh
oh is that wrong am i not allowed to say
that i thought we're on the same page
here yeah this is it think about it's
not even about
latinos or or mexicans or people from
honduras
it is about cheap immigrant labor and
it used to be who was it bernie sanders
bernie sanders warned about how the koch
brothers
brothers supported open immigration
because it would work work
great for their big corporations yeah
you get some dude who comes in working
below minimum wage no benefits because
they're under they're off the books
under the table
and then you basically have an
underclass
then vox.com the progressive website
wrote in 2016
the democratic party has become is
becoming the party of the wealthy elites
so it's no surprise then the democrats
are the ones who are now saying oh we
got to have
more immigration and open borders it's
remarkable trump ran on the republican
ticket
saying border security no free trade and
it worked because regular americans were
like yeah
i like this idea of you know america
first the big
business special interest corporations
and the ultra wealthy were like
how am i going to hire ultra cheap
labor with no rights if the republican
is doing this all of a sudden the
democrats were now like yeah open
borders
even though what in 2008 2010 you had
democrats who were like we have to build
a border security barrier
that was due the 2006 the secure fence
yeah
joe biden voted for voted for that
offense so you're calling joe biden a
racist
oh snap i think he called himself that
but and and so even even with all that
and that's why
when they're saying oh you know uh
president trump's not building any new
fence just replacing the old one well
the 2000 the one that was built in 2006
was basically just glorified chicken
wire
and you can be easily cut into within
minutes right and so this new one that
that they're replacing along with areas
where there was no barrier
it takes hours and the whole point is to
slow them
down and to actually get border patrol
agents to that area so that they can
either stop them or arrest them and so
it's just a lot of misinformation a lot
of
you know yeah rhetoric as it typically
does but because i've been there i've
been
all over el paso laredo san diego
and it's just it's just amazing when you
like when you're actually
there and you see it and you see the
difference it's just it's just
amazing it's remarkable how the
democrats really rely on you not knowing
anything
and so they'll be like donald trump
didn't build new border wall he only
replaced existing wall
if you've never seen it you're imagining
this giant wall and trump comes in and
just
takes out a wall and puts in a wall and
nothing changed and then when you
actually look at it
the original wall was like some
fence post with a single like log across
it
that you could just like walk and limbo
under yeah and then trump put triple
reinforced you know barricades with b
with cbp
in between and it's like yeah those are
very different things
and then when they're like yeah but
trump should be building new wallets
like but those are the hot spots that
the trump supporters
wanted secured right so like trump
wasn't giving his supporters a 30-foot
big beautiful concrete wall from sea to
shining sea paid for by mexico
but he was reinforcing areas with you
know strong security in a border wall
where it was most effective
yeah also the conversation changed
because previously before we had
individuals like bernie sanders that
were talking about how
if we have a lot of people entering the
labor force
wages are going to go down on the basic
understanding of supply and demand
economics
that conversation's not happening
anymore that conversation about the
average worker the average person trying
to make a living wage
that's not factored in anymore and it
should be and that should be a big part
of the conversation
i think it's just special interests they
they they want to make a quick buck
they've hijacked it's really clever i'll
put it this way
you know it's a lot easier to
[Music]
to be on the side of social justice and
have all these institutions supporting
you
but i got to say these people who think
they're fighting for you know social
justice and things like that
you you really think these billion
dollar corporations and these meat
packing plants
care about their workers look when they
slap a rainbow sticker over their logo
they're doing it so that you stop
fighting against them
and it works it does not completely well
i'm not gonna i'm not gonna be naive
enough or or you know stupid enough
to try and argue that legitimate
principled left-wing activists are gonna
stop arguing against corporations
because they put a rainbow up
but a lot of the establishment democrat
voters the people who don't
investigate news who are not
particularly active stop being active
when they're like yeah we did it
coca-cola agrees with us
they told everyone to be less white the
fight's over oh there you go
by the way do you guys have any coke no
coca-cola coca-cola
no we probably do have coke products
somewhere why do you want them to drink
oh no i just want to be less white oh
yeah
me too did you guys see the the g prime
85 comic oh
the rts the art we have on the walls is
from george alex opolis and he made one
where it's a white woman being baptized
in coca-cola
that's messed up what was the tagline
with that uh i forgot the title
of diabetes yeah yeah but the power of
diabetes
i grant you away from your whiteness or
something like that
are you thinking about my time in la i
worked at a restaurant for a long time
and had a lot of friends there that were
from
the central america that came over
illegally and were basically
extracting wealth from the country
because they would get paid in cash
and then they would send the money to
mexico to their families
and then they would work in the u.s for
a couple years and then leave and go be
super rich in mexico
relatively rich yeah and they were super
cool great friends
um and it was a small business so
they're basically it's not just the big
corporations but if the small business
can't survive
if they have to pay full wages it's hard
to pay taxes and rent and everything
there was a big movement for a while
about local currencies do you guys know
about this
like ithaca hours was a big thing where
basically there was money that was only
good in the town of ithaca new york
so if you worked they could be like we
could pay you in u.s dollars or ithaca
hours
and this this it was like one hour of
labor equaled a one
hour note and you could trade it for
food and goods
in this place so it had real value among
the community
what what this did was it ensured that
the trade medium could not leave the
city
right so if you've got a city like
detroit and then the auto plants close
down and leave
now there's no more dollars coming in
people don't have anything to trade with
so with local currencies that currency
is always there
that's why i think it's relevant to
bring up with what you were saying ian
when people come to the u.s work under
the table
and don't pay taxes i'm not saying none
of them pay taxes i'm saying but when
the specific
when they specifically don't they're not
giving back to the system they're
getting from
they're using our infrastructure then
that money is extracted from the system
and sent overseas to whatever country
their family is in
their families then can then use that
because the standard standard of living
will be lower
so it goes a lot further in those places
but that means there is less currency in
that town
to circulate among the people who live
there ultimately
an extraction of the labor value of that
area the
the re so it's basically like the labor
being brought in
is being traded away to other countries
and other places
over time it's an extraction from the us
you combine that with outsourcing
factoring factories being sent overseas
and open borders and yeah you're going
to see
seriously detrimental economic effects
in this country and that's why you get a
donald trump
because regular americans look at this
when you look at the original thing we
were talking about the democrats saying
trump support are bad
and trump supporters saying illegal
immigration bad it sounds like the trump
supporters the conservatives the
republicans
are looking at the data and thinking
what will make things better in this
country well we got a problem with
illegal immigration for a variety of
reasons
the democrats are like republicans are
bad it's like that's not a policy
problem that doesn't mean anything
republicans are actually saying this is
an issue
what do the democrats do to combat the
fact that republicans are talking about
a legitimate policy debate
they say they're racist they just hate
brown people that's the only explanation
they hate brown people they're
xenophobic i hate myself
yeah how dare you be yeah you be
conservative and and not white that's
not allowed oh i've been called a race
trader multiple times
it's great i love how they tell they
tell non-white people to be race traders
uh i'm sorry not to not to be race
traders but then they call they tell
white people to be race traders
you know what i mean yeah so like they
have that whiteness chart that was like
at that school and it said like be a
race trader and it's like okay go tell
it to anybody who's not white no
and then i say but it's not about race
yeah that was a principal in new york
city who sent a pamphlet
to all the parents in that high school
that by the way
you know there was i think i think 70
percent 17 percent of the kids were
white
that that it's good to be a white trader
like what yes uh we could probably pull
up the article new york city principal
hands out
woke pamphlet and then you could see the
pamphlet in itself it was based off of
some
university professor that created a
scale of whiteness asking white people
to rate themselves
and one of the better scales to be at is
to be a a white
uh race trader um that's right because
you're like either complicit in white
supremacy
exactly here we go yeah i found it yeah
okay okay so it is from we got this one
from syracuse.com
new york principal asks students parents
to reflect on their
whiteness and he has there's this tweet
christopher ruffa who we've had he's
great
uh is the one who i think he broke the
story and that's the eight white
identities
i think we talked about this in the show
like the other day or whatever but it's
it's definitely worth bringing up
because it literally says to be a white
traitor
it's like it's green you know it's like
white supremacist is red bad bad
red and then white privilege is like
orange it's like there's like a wheel
where it's like
red to yellow to green what is that
white voyeurism
i don't know what that means like you
you like people
watching you like watching white people
right that's what it means right no yeah
that's a boy yeah yeah exhibitionism is
when you like people watching you right
right right
yeah and voyeurism is when you like
watching others yep really weird
like you like watching white people and
then there's white benefit
white confessional white critical white
traitor
and white abolitionist white
confessional yeah this is a cult
man it's it's it's a weird race cult
yeah
yeah i i just want them to stop putting
making latinx a thing oh my gosh kleenex
yeah
i just well well and then um i forgot i
forgot who tweeted it but they they
showed they tweeted a picture of an
article i think it was like a food
magazine but it was a philippines
where it's just like i mean it's just
it's just completely insulting
i mean well one it's like they're
starting to realize that how machismo
and
how actually gendered the spanish
language is and i mean
well there you go at the end of every
spanish word it's either
a male or female romantic yeah yeah and
they go
and so it goes against that orthodoxy of
gender fluid
fluidity and all and all this stuff and
so it's just
they're trying to act like well we're
saving you from yourselves of being
sexist and oppressive towards people who
don't identify as that it's just like
well
or maybe you're being raised you're the
one being racist because you're
literally destroying the foundation
of the language of minorities you speak
spanish yeah
a little bit i'll speak a little bit i
just love the idea of them saying latinx
but they don't actually know how to
speak the language could you imagine
trying to speak spanish where you
replaced the ozines with exes
oh oh they're headaches they well one
they they look at you weirdos
it was like uh there was a gallup poll i
believe it was a gallup that that showed
it was like 90 percent of hispanics had
never even heard
of that and how do you even describe
latin x like what does it mean where did
it come from because i don't even like
it it's just it's just to denote that
you're just trying to make a gender
neutral to be sensitive to others but
but like the overall latino community
just rejects it and so
yeah i got it pulled up about one in
four u.s hispanics have heard of latinx
but just three percent use it read the
next line young hispanic women among
those most likely to use the terms
the chicks college yep how do you how do
you how do you
so it's not just spanish though it's
like romance languages have gendered
words
so like bon journix what is
what mussolini changed the uh was the
linux
the gender of the success you guys ever
read music yeah yeah it's good
the river the the great italian river uh
was a
had the female gender and he made it
male and was like we are a masculine
country so
there is something dangerous about you
know
take making something male or female
dominating i think
against could you could oppress a gender
that way but i don't know if it
necessarily does
the argument i made was so uh you you
just speak a little bit you guys speak a
little bit of spanish
yeah what is uh what does nino mean
little guy
little boy what does ninos mean little
boys
what does nina mean little girl what
does nina's mean
little girls but what if i said los
ninos and pointed to a group of school
children what does that mean yeah
boys and girls well it can be okay yeah
right because so
yeah so the point i would always bring
up is the word that's supposed to be for
boy
could actually reference girls as well
but women get an exclusive word just for
themselves
that's privilege so if you see a group
of children boys and girls you would say
los ninos but nino is masculine yet
women get included in the masculine as
well
but men don't get included in the
feminine so i'm not seriously
complaining with the language but i was
actually talking it's like
15 years ago something that's a feminist
who was complaining to this about me
when i was like teenager in chicago and
i was like how is it
how is it fair that you know women get
exclusive words to describe themselves
but the masculine words are used to
describe
both so women get both words i was being
somewhat facetious to point out the
language itself is not sexist
it's just true it's just a way to
describe things
but give look man you could make
something up and
someone probably could do this find
something that could be presumably
perceived as sexist
and then they'll latch onto it i don't
know start arguing that we should
we did you know that the modern banana
was
artificially selected so it did not
evolve naturally
humans were picking the bananas that
they liked
and then only replanting the ones that
were better and better
eventually we end up with this big
sugary wad that's not even got seeds in
it you know what i mean
like original bananas used to have all
these different all these different
seeds it's very starchy and not sweet
so what you got to do now is you tell
them it's sexist it was the men
choosing the dick-shaped fruit what yeah
because of patriarchy
it's about time we start artificially
selecting bananas to not be shaped like
wieners weiners no but it's the
stupidest idea ever
but you could make something like that
up oh spanish is sexist because there's
gendered language okay well then like
basically every romance language is
is sexist they're they're gonna get
there they just want to focus on the
brown people first yeah
yeah yeah yeah because it's the it's the
white progressives who who know better
for you
you know i mean it's very condescending
i mean like like i don't see like i
don't get
like two actually like quote-unquote
like triggered about stuff but that that
actually
upsets me just because just they i
understand what they're trying to do but
it just it just it's just done in such a
completely um inconsiderate and not in
in a serious way and it's self-defeating
you're taking the gender out of the
language
well right yeah well because they're
they're they're they're signaling that
we don't know that we're being sexist
and so they're coming to the rescue
look like why is why is comida food
is feminine is that is that fair it's
sexist that
food is for women like who cares we're
talking about it it's just
it's just yeah it's just it's just
whatever i mean that's why they don't
give it a second thought
the arabic's interesting i don't wanna i
don't wanna miss uh
exemplify it but i'm pretty sure in
arabic it's if a woman is
saying something or if a man is saying
something they use different language or
is it if you're talking to a woman
you use a different way of you use a
different phrase than if you're talking
to a man
that might yeah it's very impossible i
would say very strange because i'm not
used to it
i grew up uh in a polish area chicago's
got a very very large polish community
shout outs to kasmir pulaski saw a great
tweet from uh jackpot about that
but uh i didn't learn this until
recently and luke confirmed
that they actually give women different
last names
yeah so how does that work what is that
what is that what's that all about well
it's
it's feminine and male so usually
usually a polish name is about a ski
for for when it's for a man and ska when
it's for a woman
so the patriarchy of poland they don't
even give women the name of the men
they say no no you get a different one
you're a scar not a ski skis are only
for men
see that's the patriarchy my dad likes
god music there you go
the funny thing the funny thing about it
though is like i don't know if that's
sexist or not but you could argue
it is you can say it's not fair the men
refuse to give the women their full name
and give them
the derivative ska instead of the true
ski but then you could also argue like
modern feminism in america
where it's like i shouldn't have to take
the last name of the man anyway
there's always a way to frame the
argument to make it seem like someone's
being bigoted when it literally doesn't
right
it's just so tiring the word men is in
the word women
so that's sexist the word he is in the
word she
so that's sexist they've tried doing it
with the
story yeah yeah yeah w-o-m-x-m
story her story it's it's you know it's
uh
there's a really funny meme where
someone said like
for a while feminists were claiming that
woe wo means belong to
so woe man means property of men but
that's actually not true
the original uh um etymology i believe
of the word is where men and whitman
and so that's where werewolf comes from
so a weirman was a male man was a male
human
and a whiffman was a male a female human
and then
over time probably because men were the
ones engaging in political affairs
the patriarchy the the wear dropped off
and just became
men and then women retained the the
whiffman
you know suffix prefix or whatever so
long story short
there's there's like evolution of
language happens and it's really easy to
make anything seem like a conspiracy
or or or you know bigoted or racist and
they exploit that
they exploit sophistry to convince
unsuspecting people who have who are of
good faith and good will
into doing for them and for for those
that think critically
you know to the to the chagrin of the
new york times they don't fall for this
stuff
they end up watching shows like this you
guys are great but a lot of people just
fall for cnn
they'll turn it on and they'll be like
you know latinx and they'll go yes
i saw disney also they had when they
were celebrating
hispanic heritage month they and that's
the other thing too you could just say
hispanic
like like that's like that's generous
too yeah it's like there's
or latin america i mean there's just
there there's other options like why
why do you have to go after that and
again i don't want to like
seem like i'm just triggered over words
but it's just it's just it's it's the
deeper
uh mindset that they have of like we
know better than you do
and you're it's and if you go against us
you're i love it
it's a most it's an ideology derived
mostly from white leftists
to tell minorities how to speak and i'm
like how do you define white supremacy
a bunch of white academics of privilege
telling minorities what to say and think
and do
i mean that sounds like you know better
it sounds a bit like white supremacy to
me
you know i'm not going to tell you you
can say whatever you want i don't know i
don't think it's about
gender i don't think it's about sex or
anything like that i don't think it's
about gender roles i think it's about
controlling the narrative and this is
something we've talked about in the past
we've talked about changing the language
so you can change stuff like the laws
i think it's a matter of sneaky trying
to force the evolution of a language to
suit your own
power goals i i honestly think it's
that's true like we talked about how if
you can change the definition of the
word gender
then every law on the books becomes a
different law
so when the law was written right like
the 1960 1964 civil rights act and they
say
you know or or derivative policies in
various jurisdictions when they say
you may not discriminate on the basis of
gender well back then they specifically
meant
male or female today the activists left
at all in all these institutions has
changed the definition of gender
once people accept it they say look the
law says you can't discriminate the
basis of gender
well i'm you know hydro gender so you
can't discriminate
and then they show up dressed up in a
full body you know jacuzzi suit
or something you know more actually
they'd be pretty sweet have you seen
those jacuzzi suits oh
is it real i'm pretty i think they might
be real maybe maybe it's something i saw
maybe i dreamed
yeah that's like a fever dream right
there if you don't have coke no i think
i saw it on tv once
i don't know but you know what i mean
i'm just trying to be absurd like
if if if the law was originally intended
to address
males and females and now that we've
changed language you're going to argue
the law is different that's a way to
exploit the system
to change laws without actually having
the votes to change the laws
it seems to be a lot of what they're
doing i didn't think of it that way yeah
i do think a lot of it is just random
though like when they say wymixon do you
guys know what wimxin is no
w-o-w-o-m-x-n or or or phlox
instead of folks oh fu yeah it's
folks with an ex
i don't know how that's yeah for no
reason i i saw that i saw
i saw that pop up like a month ago i was
like how did where did that come from
because they like putting x's on things
it's it's like a little kid being like
i'm gonna call myself
the the thunder smasher that's my new
name and the mom is like
billy that's not your name your name is
william stop calling yourself
thundersmasher
and you can't write on your exam at
school thundersmasher anymore because
your name is william it's like no i'm
i'm thunder smasher it's like a little
kid just trying to be cool no
i'm going to put an x at the end of my
award because x's are cool you want to
know what's really funny about the
letter x
x means christ in christianity so i want
everybody to think about that every time
they see the word woman center folks
think about it
there you go thinking about them
thinking about religion because
the people that want to crush the
patriarchy or undo this
this there's something to it because
like if you look at the way the bible is
written
eve came from adam's rib in the story
like the man
everyone knows that humans are born from
women that's just the way things are
wasn't lilith first was that is that she
was saying she was satan's wife
oh wasn't there a woman before eve no
really you sure yeah
what was that 100 yeah they wrote the
book for this like mystical
woman was created from a dude's rib like
look the man came
first the man is the center in the
beginning but like
no he was born from a woman they just
write her into the story
and so these people want to kind of
trash that i mean there's really a bunch
of old white dudes
wrote the bible and like had the council
of nicaea and rewrote took out what they
wanted to make it tell a story
to give men power but the women are the
most power
like the women are the center of the
family they are the creator of the human
and so i see these people wanting to
kind of
bend or or break things back to the way
i just a different way i don't know
i just have to you know interject uh
right go ahead interject
lilith appears as adam's first wife who
was created the same time
and from the same clay as adam this
contrasts with eve who was created from
one of adam's ribs
lilith is the legend of the first woman
is a 19th century rendition of the old
rabbinical legend of lilith the first
woman whose life story was dropped
unrecorded from the early world
and whose home hope and eden were passed
to another woman
so it's not in the bible right okay yeah
well it does
are they yeah yeah you're right right
right right right right right right
right
right
right
right
right
right right right unbiblical so maybe it's
it's an old rabbinical legend
so i guess she's uh interesting
interesting how do we get here
i don't know i'm talking about like
gender language and
like is it male dominated did they build
those languages i don't really know the
history of um
romance we've got we've got another
story in the similar vein of
a creepy school check this out we've got
from the daily mail buffalo public
school
claims all white people perpetuate
systemic racism and force
kindergartners to watch video of dead
black children to warn them about racist
police and state-sanctioned violence
fatima morel is associate superintendent
for culturally and linguistically
responsive initiatives
at buffalo public schools in new york
morale has introduced a new curriculum
lesson plans
and teacher training the teachers are
encouraged courage to be more woke in
their efforts at anti-racism
morale suggests teaching kindergartner
classes about children killed by police
with videos featuring trayvon martin
tamir rice and others
older pupils pupils learn all white
people play a part in perpetuating
systemic racism a whistleblower told
city journal about the news the new
lessons
new lesson plans marella's yet to
comment on the controversial
uh new teaching programs i wonder if
they have some some photos
so there's one post where it says i am
ayana i was sleeping
i am trayvon i was walking anti-racism a
powerful collection of anti-racist
policies that lead to racial equity
and are substantiated by anti-racist
ideas they're indoctrinating kids
they're teaching kids this is illegal
the 1964 civil rights act says you can't
discriminate on the basis of race
these people they're being referred to
as neo-racist i just consider them
like good old passion yeah it's good
old-fashioned racist it's just it's the
same thing
it didn't change it's still racism
they're literally like
that race is bad okay well that you're
racist they're doing it in schools
imagine the psychology of a small child
hearing this and seeing
just the traumatic imagery of death
and then that being pushed along with of
course a big propaganda we have to also
understand
they use a lot of graphic images to push
this because when you're emotionally
shocked
when you're in a constant state of fear
you don't critically think
and for for kids to see something
traumatic and then be told hey
uh if you're white you're perpetrating
systemic racism no matter who you are
what you do because of the way you were
born that is just absolutely absurd
sickening and crazy and destroying the
youth of this nation
so there's this image that we've talked
about a bit before and i'm sure most of
you are familiar with it's the
the equity fence which uh is this meme
it's fairly viral and it looks like this
one got a
got a graphical update look at that very
very nice on the left it says equality
there is a tall man a medium-sized man
and a short well i don't know if they're
a woman
person and they're all standing on a
crate
the short person can't see the fence is
in the way the the media person
can see over the fence and the tall
person can clearly see the next panel on
the right says equity
now the tall person has no crate so he
but he can still see he's tall
the piers in the middle still has one
crate but the short person now has two
another short person can see the
baseball game as well my favorite
response this is from libertarians where
they say they're all stealing they are
they're all stealing because there's you
can pay for tickets but i want to point
something out
when they're teaching kids about this
stuff and they show this image
what they're not explaining to the kids
because all the people here are brown
skin they're all of the same race
what they're not telling you is in on
the side that says equity
where you have the three people standing
up imagine the tall person
is of one particular race then imagine
someone from the government
taking away from that person and giving
it to someone else
based on their race now imagine that the
person who is tall
is actually a black person and the
person who is short as a white person
would you justify the government coming
and taking from the black community to
give
to the white community their argument is
well we just
know who is quantifiably privileged or
underprivileged
but you don't know would it make sense
for the government to take away from
like a working class
you know white family where the dad is a
carpenter and the mom
is is you know is it auto sales car
sales person and they take money from
them and give it to
oprah's family well this is meaningless
well this is the thing we even had
one of the head board members of the new
york city education
organization publicly come out and say
if there's a rich
or middle class black person and a poor
white kid
resources have to go to the middle class
rich black person because of systemic
historic racism so we have literal heads
of education in new york city arguing
for this
and there's a third meme that that's
related to the beam that you have up
there
and it's a third panel and it says when
government
gets involved and it shows the tall
person and
the the middle person getting their legs
chopped off
as a representation of whenever the
government gets involved that i tweeted
a long time ago which i think is also
perfectly representative of what
actually happens when the government
tries to solve a problem
that usually they're the ones that
perpetrated it and created it
they usually make it a lot worse so i
can't find it i'm trying to find it
there's a bunch of silly versions of
this though there's like liberation
there's no fence anymore i like that one
because it makes no sense
because there's like so does the
outfield go forever apparently so it's
like the
outfielders can keep running and there's
no home runs it's all an rbi
yeah the rules don't matter they're
teaching kids this stuff and they're not
teaching kids enough to explain anything
to them about what it really means it's
just
indoctrination these kids are going to
grow up as dogmatic tribalists
i'll tell you what's funny they they
many on the left had similar things
about religion
you know back in the day kids growing up
with religious indoctrination oh it's a
problem i don't care sure fine i'll tell
you what
it doesn't justify you becoming the
dogmatic religious lunatics
but i tell you it's really crazy
watching this
cult spread there's an organ
organization called free press the free
press it's
called freepress.net i used to know
these guys i've
i actually only a few years ago was
sitting down with one of the guys from
the free press
talking about freedom of speech freedom
of of the press our ability to
communicate
and then in the past year two years the
organization has called for
banning and censoring misinformation and
the far-right and political ideas they
don't like and i'm like
how have you gone so insane with this
cult that an
organization called the free press would
launch
a campaign to censor people based on
their opinions
well we saw democrats in congress
recently write that letter
talking about uh banning fox news and
one america it's just it's it's really
really concerning and in turkey carlson
uh he he's been one of the main targets
uh from media matters and and what have
you and so
he's really been sounding the alarm on
that and it really is becoming a
big problem in terms of rhetoric that
we're seeing from
people in power yeah and so it's just
it's
it's completely absurd just because it's
cnn and msnbc they do
how do you how do you fight this kind of
thing right it's like it's like a
religion
home school uh this i mean reading this
article
really really uh made me proud of
understanding the larger homeschool
network in new hampshire that
that that happens in that particular
state it's one of the largest
homeschooling states and also the the
smartest state compared to of course iqs
of other states
which tells you a lot because when you
give up your child to the institution of
the state for quote education
they're not you're not really getting
educated you're getting indoctrinated
into the propaganda this is this
the newest level of propaganda that
they're introducing people so they could
go along with their bigger agenda the
newer agenda
but of course there was an older agenda
the school system
has failed our children it has failed me
it has failed a large
number of individuals and it's not there
to uplift people it's not there to help
people
find their skills their passions their
loves it's not there to help people in
their journeys in life
it's there to keep them in institutions
so they could be good factory workers
and that's what school systems were
built on
by the rockefeller institute trying to
of course rinse and repeat
create good factory workers what was it
michael malus who said that
one of the only places a child will
experience violence will be in a school
michael said that yeah and uh i'm not
sure if it was michael who said this but
someone said they're effectively prisons
yeah yeah yeah yeah michael said that
yeah and uh
i agree um i mean i think schools public
schools particularly
i've been a private school private
school i i went to catholic school for
the first you know
up until fifth grade and then sixth
grade i transferred to public school
public school is just awful
there's like limited supervision they
don't care the kids are not really
learning things it was just really
really bad
i mean i saw extreme amounts of violence
uh in new york city there was a kid that
got shot in my classroom
like i can't even go into just some of
the graphic details of what i saw
growing up there but essentially when
you really look at it
it's run like a prison the same
companies that build the schools or the
same companies that also build the
prisons i remember visiting my friend in
prison just a few months ago and being
like
this looks a lot like my school and then
i remember like oh yeah
they work for the same kind of
contracting organizations that build
these larger institutions and it's not
just the construction of these
uh buildings it's also the way that
they're run it's also the
the way that teachers bark orders that
students scream at them tell them to
stay in line tell them to
to regurgitate whatever they say and if
they don't have the same opinions as
they do they get punished
and essentially even in college if you
have a
opinion that a professor doesn't like
they're going to give you a
worse grade than if you had a you know
opinion that actually
disagreed with them think about where
the school stuff leads to right check it
out
you're gonna have right now you've got
all these teacher unions saying we're
not reopening we're not gonna go back to
work
we don't wanna go back to school but pay
us not essential sure they say but we
wanna make sure the schools are safe i
really just don't believe you fine
whatever they don't wanna reopen schools
wealthier families
are just homeschooling their kids and
they're putting them in learning pods
where they hire tutors
the tutor gets 20 to 30 kids that
tutor's probably making bank to be
honest
because all these parents are now like
we'll pay pay 100 bucks a week or
something
and they got 30 kids so these tutors are
just raking in the dough
teaching a various group of kids
throughout the day these kids are
getting one-on-one education in a small
classroom
with a professional edu you know
educator to some degree
these kids when they get older they're
gonna be smarter better
faster stronger all of these things
because they're getting well they're
getting
invested in these other kids who are
going to these schools are being
indoctrinated
are going to be well they're being kept
out of school they're being given given
very awful uh education they're getting
these zoom classes most the kids don't
even pay attention
they're not going to school the teachers
don't care the teachers don't want to be
there the teachers are arguing keeping
the schools shut down
and then when they are there they're
getting indoctrinated with garbage so
what happens
you're going to end up with two 20 year
olds one 20 year old
from the pods from the learning pods not
the not the
dystopian pods and they're going to be
sitting there and they're going to be
socially savvy they'll have grown up
around adults they'll have learned the
intricacies of you know normal human
living and they're gonna have a
conversation with an employer and say
you know i i worked very hard i was you
know i ran my family's business when i
was 18 i did this
i was educated at these you know these
institutions i did homeschool for these
years
and they're going to be like oh this
person's articulate you know well
thought out
i think they can bring a lot to my
company then they're going to look at
the next resume and the person's going
to be like
well i am a person of color and it means
you have to hire me
and um i didn't go to school because the
teachers didn't want to show up
but i did learn about equity from
watching mtv videos on youtube
and they're going to be like uh i'm not
going to hire you
like you don't bring value now the one
thing that could change that of course
is if we get really extreme leftist
draconian woke policy where the
companies like in california are forced
to bring on you know
women and minorities to their board so
that's like if you're companies of a
certain size you
have to fire a white guy and then hire a
woman of color or something
so then maybe that will actually happen
where you're gonna have people show up
and they're gonna be like
well you have to hire me so there you go
and then you end up like venezuela
i mean i i know venezuela is kind of the
go-to example but
in venezuela man they make jobs for the
sake of making jobs you know
they don't need a job well well just
make it and just there could be a job
for one person
let's say the job uh the example i often
give is when i was trying to buy a cell
phone in venezuela
it was like five different people i had
to talk to buy a cell phone
because they just created the jobs
because they need to have jobs
in the us you walk into a t-mobile or an
att or a sprint there's one person
you're like yeah i want a phone like
okay
they pulled the phone they sign you up
you give them the credit card they say
bye-bye
the amount of mandatory signage that
businesses need in venezuela is
absolutely ridiculous
they at least they have to dedicate an
entire wall to all the permits
to all the regulations to all the rules
and also a huge
no smoking sign and a huge no
guns are welcome here sign in caracas
venezuela
at one time the murder capital of the
world
and it's not anymore uh there it
fluctuates between other latin american
countries uh but when i went there it
was the number one murder capital in the
entire world
they outlawed people having firearms and
guess what
homicides through firearms skyrocketed
because all the people were disarmed and
only the criminals had the firearms
even private security in some instances
wasn't allowed to have
firearms and the police officers were
working with of course
politically motivated institutions and
groups that protected each other
meanwhile other people were left to of
course the gangs
and i forgot the exact name of this one
motorcycle gang that was wreaking havoc
on a whole bunch of communities but but
again when you go to venezuela it's been
wrecked by absolute violence to the
point where police officers and other
authorities were literally telling me
hey if you're driving at night and uh
there's a red light
just don't don't worry don't stop just
go right up ahead yeah
i i was i was a dirty smoker at the time
too and the hotel was like no no
no no no no no smoke here i'm like okay
i'll go over there they're like
no no no no no no no you're going to get
killed there i'm like
what do you want me to do i'm going to
smoke too now i'm going to screw you man
like cause i'm not nervous
i'm all nervous i don't smoke anymore
that was a bad phase that i had uh don't
smoke it's really bad for you
but but again it just shows you the
utter lunacy of more government
i got to do this i got to do this this
because it's it's it's
it is more government but it's also how
the left has become the moral
authoritarian so let me let me start the
segment by asking you guys a question
which political party
pop quiz everybody was trying to get
content and music banned in the 90s
which political faction the republicans
it was the republicans yes
i was born in 96 so i don't remember oh
yeah well late
late 90s i remember so uh magic the
gathering for instance we actually have
this card downstairs called
unholy strength magic the gathering of
course is a strategic
card game with fantasy themes and
there's an image of a guy with a
pentagram behind him and it was
conservative religious families
who complained and forced the company to
remove the image of the pentagram
because it was satanic
check out this story illinois lawmaker
seeks ban
of grand theft auto game following rise
in
carjackings and which political party
does this illinois lawmaker who is
trying to ban a video game belong to
what would you guess well the the party
affiliation is not in the title so
i know so the rule so the rule
that's that's is democratic i think he's
a statist
is he a statist yes sure
he's a democrat a democrat is trying to
get a video game banned
this is it i'm sorry everybody if first
of all when was the last grand theft
auto game
made 2013 no no more recent than that no
gta 5 20
23 16 yeah no i think you're looking up
i'm sure yeah
but i remember seeing so many
republicans when when one of the grand
theft autos had a scene
with a working woman in 2013. is it
really they ported it to pc later
yeah yeah yeah but i remember i remember
that wait
wait wait gta 5 came out for ps3
is that really the latest grand theft
auto it's been it's been it's been a hot
minute yeah it's been a while
it's been a hot minute so listen listen
listen you got a guy
a democrat trying to ban a video game
that's what going on like eight
years old because carjackings went up i
blame you ian i see the ladies you're
it doesn't make people want to carjack
cars it just makes it easier to do
that's that's what i think he watches
the video with ian describing what he
said it came to that conclusion
the one super chatter said like video
game violence i was like do video games
make people
more commit more violence i was like no
it doesn't make people want to do it it
just makes it easier to pull the trigger
they do it that's why they train
soldiers exactly yeah
we talked to uh we talked to somebody
about that they say so the military will
use
these uh the guy from the ranch yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
it doesn't make people more likely to it
makes it easier for those too so that i
understand the family guy did a whole
cutaway about that
about that specific grand theft auto
where peter loses memory and she's like
oh just here play this game so you can
remember how to drive and then you see
him carjacking
so this this illinois guy rep marcus
evans jr has introduced a bill that
would amend a pre-existing law
banning certain video games from being
sold to minors his amendment would ban
the sale of games with subject matter
including motor vehicle theft with a
driver or passenger present
the amendment has yet to be voted on
there would have be there have been
renewed debates around the ban of
carjack ban after carjackings among
young people have gone up recently
the bill would prohibit the sale of some
of these games that promote the
activities that we're suffering from in
our communities
a 16 year old was arrested and charged
with carjacking on monday days ago
there were two 15 year olds arrested i
got to just say i really don't think
these kids are playing gta and being
like dude i got an idea
let's go carjack for real yeah that's so
smart and they high high-five and they
go outside and they're like yo
give me your car and that's that's that
i don't know we live in a generation of
tide pods
that's true nobody was eating tide pods
that was not
but when it comes to intelligence by and
large when it comes to our education
system we are failing that's the bigger
point i'm making here
for sure but but also most importantly
especially with this grand theft auto
thing i
i believe it was republicans that made
it so you needed to show an id card
to show that you're old enough to buy
certain video games just a few years ago
i remember there was such a massive
outcry against gta there was one
particular scene with a working woman
that everyone was
screaming about and they actually came
pretty close in banning the video game a
couple years ago
so it's just absolutely absurd to still
see this nonsensical argument being made
right now but it's the perfect
representation of what government is
absolutely absurd and stupid i don't i
don't know about that republican
i do think i just tried to google i
couldn't find it but i but i do have the
story where
the verge rights trump and republicans
continue to blame video games for their
failures on gun control they say
there's no evidence but it's a talking
point that has been repeated since
columbine
amazing following two uh we'll call them
mass tragic events
they say lawmakers and government
officials offers thought and prayers
they take no action
house minority leader kevin mccarthy
told fox and friends that video games
dehumanize individuals
in a speech today president trump
pointed at video games specifically
as the root cause of these events we
must have the glorification of violence
in our society he said
this includes the gruesome and grisly
video games that are now commonplace
sounds like ian when you when you said
before that
you know video games were related to
this you were far right i would like to
ask julio about this because you're
actually in the military
yeah in the reserves what what branch
the military in marine corps and what
what do you think about
violence in video games and how it
associates i mean there's
i don't think that's true in the sen in
the sense that that's
the cause for it i mean you have to look
at just
the the whole environment and obviously
who the person is
i mean i i think in terms of
desensitizing
maybe yeah but in terms of it being the
trigger
behind it no i don't know like
encouraging it encouraging it yeah
because you
you you separate the two i mean it's it
is an interesting point
that trump republicans were then
bringing up dehumanizing essentially
like we learned from the uh it was it
was the
the fellow from fortitude is that what
who were you saying fortitude
he was saying the military so i actually
i brought this up because
there's this movie called the men who
stare at goats yeah and it was this like
project where they tried doing psychic
spies it's
a real thing apparently yeah and in the
movie you've got um what's the guy's
name is it jeff bridges
the actor is that his name that's right
which one the actor in the movie the
stair menoscero goats
they're talking about how he was in
vietnam and this like vietnamese woman
runs out into a field
and all of the american soldiers they
don't shoot and then he's like what are
you doing start shooting and they shoot
up to purposefully miss and so the dude
who is here said
the way they combat that is using active
targets like
actually they used to do they used to
just do like a target now they do a
shape like a person
and they do first person video games so
that now it's in the people's minds of
what a person looks like
so the the general idea is that video
games don't make people more violent
but a violent person would this would
help them
essentially if they were going to commit
an act they would not be averse to
shooting a person
right i mean i i i don't know
i mean i again i just i i just have a
hard time i just have a hard time
believing that that that's that's the
main factor that's going to
drive somebody i mean and you look at
the i mean you just look at the
the the history i mean you you don't
want to talk about
be careful when i talk about mental
illness but adam lanza from the the new
new town right i mean there's there's
just so many other
things although i think he did i think
he did play video games though i think
well i i think everybody plays video
games
right right dungeons and dragons was
going to make kids go crazy
and it's violence i mean i will say i
mean because like from from the riots
that
that i've that i covered a lot i mean it
was just back to back to back
and and i i found myself being very
bored
and and so i think there's an adrenaline
aspect for certain high stress
events uh and not necessarily school
shootings but i can see that because
there was some stuff that would happen
that that i would see and
report on and it would be sad and be
tragic but i'd have a hard time
finding emotion behind it just because i
had seen it over and over and over
personally that would be the decent
disease
that would be kind of the
desensitization aspect and so like i
would recognize that it would
like okay like this is bad and this is
sad but um
it didn't have the same effect the very
first they do this to many police
departments they play very violent riot
footage
and officers getting hurt right before
they go out i've seen the
many reports of this uh before they go
out cover many protests or a lot of them
are jacked up a lot of them are
you know ready to to you know prepare to
defend themselves and
most protests usually don't don't get
violent they're becoming more and more
violent
uh but again psychologically the video
is such an important component in in
making people
realize that's that's there's something
else bigger out there
it plays on the imagination but it also
plays on your visceral senses
where you get to see it and you get
inundated in it in such a way where you
believe you're actually
in it so video is one of the biggest
forms of propaganda
that we should be of course made aware
of and especially question when
certain traumatic videos are being
played over and over and over again
especially on mainstream media dude i
was watching you were watching a movie
yesterday or something and it was like a
guy just hitting another guy just
beating on his face
oh taken taken taking three yet another
violent movie i mean we're talking about
so much violence in the movie industry
it is punching even all the marvel
movies just punching and beating and
throwing and blasting listen
everything like 90 i'm i'm just giving
an exaggerated number but
the overwhelming majority of content is
violence guns
every every marvel movie every marvel
these are some of the biggest movies
ever made
literally all of them violence the
mandalorian mandalorians for all
violence
yeah it was great yeah yeah yeah game of
thrones violence war
video games violence conflict the
biggest games like even minecraft has
violence in it to a certain degree yeah
sure it's not the worst i shouldn't rag
on minecraft
but you look at some of the biggest
games fortnite violence i don't know
people are still playing fortnite
uh grand theft auto the game where you
drive around run people over and do
crazy things
there is this component of video games
that conflict is
one of the big components of our
entertainment
i wonder what it is i'd love to talk to
a psychologist or you know a
psychologist about this
what about violence is like such an
entertaining value for us
is it because it's conflict because it's
risk it's a threat it scares you
and then you overcome it what we've seen
from this is there have been feminists
who want to create what what people call
walking sims
walking simulators video games where
it's like your your mission is to go and
hold hands with someone and earn points
because they want to get away from that
but people don't like it
people like even if you go back to mario
like the original modern nes
you play a dude who runs around punching
bricks and stomping turtles
and then kicking them it's like it's
fast-paced geometric competition kind of
like throwing
baseballs at each other like dodgeball
but it doesn't have to be
shooting someone and killing them it
just is in the visage of that
so like i think why people like it is
because it's fast-paced geometry
and you're learning how like what's that
splatoon what's splatoon
you are a bunch of like squid critter
people and you sprayed paint on them
yeah same fast-paced geometry so that's
what that's what we're really learning
is how to interact um hand-eye
coordination
we're challenging each other to see
who's got faster reflexes
but it's in the guise of a violent gun
you know it's the ar it's all these
realistic guns the graphics are getting
so realistic
that if you're in it in like vr you'll
really maybe start to believe you're
killing someone like it's possible
i got it right now the big problem is
not the republicans for the most part
this it's a democrat who wants to ban
these video games the only thing we have
to do to make sure that nobody comes and
bans our video games
is make all of the bad guys have donald
trump's faces
there it is because think about it
republicans might actually complain and
say i demand this game banned but who's
going to listen to the republicans they
can't get anything done
they'll be like i am upset about the you
these games got to get banned i'll say
get out of here
shut up and then if you make all the all
all of the
npcs any character that could die has
donald trump's face
the left will be like i see nothing
wrong with this all violent
you made the most gruesome and brutal
violent video game like doom was legit
like super violent but just you know
make it trump and and they'll
they'll allow it they'll stop
complaining they'll immediately come to
the defense
someone should make a mod for gta where
everyone's faces donald trump and show
it to that democrat and he'll go
oh oh you know what i think this game is
actually okay i withdraw my bill
i i'm a huge video game nerd as you
probably know if you don't know i'm a
huge video game nerd leo um
i got really mixed feelings about video
game violence like i wasn't allowed to
watch violent movies growing up yes i'm
here
because they didn't want to twist my
mind my parents i saw a nightmare in elm
street too when i was like 10 and i
remember the veins getting sucked out of
that guy and it like stuck in my brain
for
mon for ye still to this day i can see
it his skin turning white as his veins
were getting it was so gro like
just messed me up and that was one thing
that i saw as a kid
i was like i wasn't allowed to watch tom
and jerry or the three stooges or
married with children like i was
and did i i'm so i'm aware like the
violence man how it can brainwash you
but i don't want to ban it i don't know
this is this is it is interesting i
think you know we do have to be careful
about what kids
are watching and and are doing but
that's not that's not incumbent upon
government
it's it's it's it's the parents it's a
family role thing we were just talking
about there's a video of ron paul that
went viral
and it is one of the most glorious
videos of ron paul ever luke was like
i've seen that video a million times
i just retweeted it i said ron paul is a
legend it's
it's basically a bunch of people who are
like ban drugs say no
and ron paul's like government shouldn't
be the one deciding what you do with
your life
but there's this really glorious moment
where he's arguing with a guy
and he goes you're not going to get
morality from the government the
government can't make you a better
person
why don't they put you on a diet you're
a little overweight and everyone's like
and i was just like yes ron paul he's
right if
if if look if you're like the government
should tell us what we can or can't do
it's like okay well they should tell you
to put down the fork
no that's not the way it works so when
it comes to video games when it comes to
south park when it comes to beavs and
butt head whatever these shows are
because you know abusive but believe it
or not it's coming back
right and and parents have complained
about it it's
your fault i'm sick and tired of this
and this is this really
for for the most part uh become endemic
on the left
i mean i know the right used to be about
banning things they're like oh these
things are bad for kids and you know we
gotta ban this art
now it's really the left it's like yo
the left are the ones coming out and
saying i should have no responsibility
it is a combat too
you said about adam lanza was pretty
enlightening like i think it goes deeper
into the the psychoactive drug
system and how it's making people crazy
and then
yeah we're talking about parents taking
responsibility for what their kids are
consuming but like
you can see you can be inundated with
violence but if you're on psychotropics
that's going to be different and what
i'm trying what i'm trying to bring up
specifically and focus on
is you've got too many people in this
country whether it's people who have
kids or somebody who just eats terrible
food who says
you should pay for my health care even
though i lay around eating
double you know big macs with extra
sauce and don't exercise
or this video game made someone crazy so
we should have the government take it
away from everybody else or
a crazy person with a gun therefore no
one should be allowed to have guns
right it's meaningless yeah i mean and
so that's why i'm
adverse to when it comes to like video
games because it's the same
line argument when it comes to gun
control and
one of the reasons why i became
conservative was looking at the various
gun control arguments
uh made by republicans and democrats and
i was thinking well
the democrats one doesn't make any sense
and you know what else are they being
misleading about and so that's kind of
how i
went down the road right right and it's
it's remarkable how
if you're if you're being logical and
you hear the conservative
argument on guns you're going to hear
something typically
they're going to say this ex like
the first memes i saw was why is this
gun band and this gun not banned
and they're the same gun so one meme is
the ruger 10 22 i saw
there's a wooden stock ruger 10 22 and
then there's a
like polymer stock with a pistol grip
ruger 10 22
literally the same gun same capacity
same firing and everything you just hold
it a little bit different
one's under risk of being banned as an
assault weapon and one isn't
it's it's meaningless so when i would
actually go to
you know the left the traditional
liberal people and say why is this gun
ban they say oh assault weapons got to
be banned and i'm like
they're the same gun it makes no sense
and you can't get a logical answer out
of these people because they don't know
what they're talking about
and so i'm just like listen if you can't
be responsible for your own life
why should i have to pay the price and
that is a serious challenge
i am actually fairly left on a ton of
policies i totally believe in
cooperative economics and systems of
government
but there is a limit we have to be
liberty oriented not authority oriented
and so what you have with these
traditional liberals is they actually i
love this meme from leftists they're
like democrats are actually
authoritarian right and i'm like yes
that's correct that is absolutely true
the democratic establishment are
somewhat
they're not super far right all at the
top but they are in the authoritarian
right spectrum
they want to take away from you they
want to dictate what you do and they are
not overtly far left but they're close
to the left
so they're they're like they're i'm
sorry they're they're they're more
authoritarian right
and there's a difference between
libertarian right where it's like hey
man do your thing be free and freely
trade
authoritarian rights are crony democrat
corporatist democrats whoever
revolving door policies prop up
international
corporations and big tech firms
empowering the corporations
and then also telling you what you can
or can't do with your life so i actually
i actually think the democrats and
republicans the democrats are fairly in
the same place
you do have progressive democrats who i
think
too much indulge in the cult stuff and
then you have a lot of good libertarian
republican candidates like politicians
people like well rand paul obviously ron
paul retired now
thomas massey and a few others you have
very few actual good principled
democrats
at all but i would say it's a tiny
fraction that are actually on the
libertarian spectrum
so i tell you if if you believe in
freedom i don't care if you're an arco
communist
far left you know critical race woke
whatever
if you're on the libertarian spectrum
and your whole thing is well i disagree
with you but i don't believe in being
violent and hurting others or forcing
people to do things
like we get along man come over have a
beer let's grab some slice grab a slice
of pizza or
vegan pizza that's what you're into and
then the laser fair capitalist can come
and
you know and then sell us his great
pizza and we can all hang out together
as long as we all agree not to oppress
and beat
and harm each other that's not what
we're getting we're getting tons of
moral authoritarians who want to use the
power of government
because they think other people
shouldn't do things or they want to
extract the value and labor from other
people
because they're not responsible for
themselves there is sometimes it's
valuable like you want to stop people
from pooping in the river that's a
metaphor that's happened before yeah but
that's not what we're talking about here
well
i think we're giving people addictive
drugs you kind of want to stop that
why because it's like pooping in their
soul no it's it's
absolutely it's making people crazy no
that's a thought you think that
it's authoritarian to stop shoving
opioids into the schools
into the shoving telling someone they
can't put something in their body as
authoritarian yes
giving but i mean they're giving people
prescriptions
i know what's better for you therefore
you shouldn't be allowed to do it yes
that's authoritarianism well that's
how the family works a family is not a
government
i know but it's a microwave house
economy means household management but
we also have to understand with the
party in charge right now this
larger authority of censorship is
intoxicating for a lot of these
individuals
and just like i said on this show
they're going to go after people in
politics and soon it's going to
translate into art
books entertainment and i think it
slowly and surely is there's a lot of
pushback against this particular video
game thing because
how absurd it is but we also have to
understand any form of censorship is
absolutely absurd it deserves to be
pushed back
and we are already seeing and have seen
a lot of comedians
hit and canceled and attacked for
telling jokes and trying to make people
laugh
which again on the on on this on its own
level is absolutely absurd and it needs
to be pushed back immediately
well i'll tell you this um i feel the
only person i well i feel bad for
uh lydia and ian right now because i can
see uh
you know obviously julio you're a person
of color and uh i
i am as well as a with my asian
background and luke as a slav
is uh is granted born and raised yeah
that
did you know this the community
coalition of communities of color said
that slavs
are uh people of color really so slavic
people please pronounce it right
is that the right way i'm sorry i'm
sorry i didn't mean to be offended
yeah yeah
i think i'm gonna make a t-shirt like
that dirty dirty blonde blue-eyed luke
white skin is not in fact white
no um you know and he does not have that
privilege
so we're allowed to make a fence of
jokes and uh ian is idea and i got the
raw into that i know right
seriously not only do we no no you have
white privilege
scottish oh are you scottish i'm i'm
irish and scottish yeah white privilege
i guess not slavic
you have white privilege i'm still like
reeling from finding out that lucas
i know me too no we did a whole thing
it's true i couldn't believe it but you
know i don't know i take the back i
actually could believe because i've made
the point before
i actually would would talk to these
people who are like white privilege and
i'm like you mean to tell me that you
think ukrainians have white privilege
and they would go well
yeah come on no like these these people
are not living
the the wealthy american like they
struggle to come to america it's
actually easier for a mexican to come to
america than ukrainian of course
like i have privilege but my parents
stayed together that's a big part of why
and i had to get a job when i was 12 so
that i wasn't like they wouldn't buy me
anything
you know i was very lucky that we got a
nintendo when i was young
we should we should all take the
privilege test have you ever seen it oh
i think so yeah i think it was from
buzzfeed i'm not sure but it's probably
from buzzfeed
yeah it was like this sounds like a
spider bar and it was like
are you you know christian or not like
how christian are you how are you
like and it's like a slider bar for your
gender did you see the guy in california
who took a dna test and came back four
percent black
and now he wants to qualify as a
minority business owner yeah
he gets all the privileges and all the
special promotions they just don't know
the pandora's box that they open
yeah it's just obviously like racism is
bad but like when
it's clever no maybe what they're doing
is actually this really clever play
where all of a sudden there will be like
luke who's like i mean come on
if if you were to describe a white
person you got dirty blonde blue eyes
lukewarkowski
like luke i'm sorry they can claim it
you're you have your blonde hair blue
eyes come on listen
they said what they said council has
spoken it's
it's it's been determined uh stop trying
to oppress me
with your designations of me as you are
clearly an
asian person that has triple white
classification
category i say triple you're right now
you're right i mean
there's a reason that asians are lumped
in with the whites especially when it
comes to the university discussion
that's been happening in the country as
well
no no you're correct because i'm i'm uh
german irish korean and japanese
triple triple white i said yeah triple
white yeah so it's a trip triple white
and uh luke i'm sorry i'm sorry for
oppressing you you better be i will i
will check my triple white privilege
triple white privilege uh but the point
i'm saying is it's this like securities
plan towards actually you know doing
away with racism
by making so that a bunch of white men
can edify as women of color
yeah if this dude is four percent black
who is white as they like
they say he looks white you can't tell
he got a dna test and he could identify
as a woman
he is now a female you know it reminds
me of that south park episode where
everyone gets their dna tests to check
out their privileges
what's happening i hear south park is
coming back right they predicted this
yeah but listen listen are they going to
deny deny it now
one of my favorite moments you guys ever
see this there was a scholarship program
for african americans and a blonde hair
blue-eyed
white kid showed up and when they were
like this is for african-americans he
was like i'm from south africa
and they were like no you have to leave
and he was like but i'm literally from
africa and they're like no get out of
here
it's a it's it's crazy south park also
predicted chad's
did they really yeah remember remember
that episode where the hippies take over
the town
oh yeah that's true yeah that that's
that that's what i compare apartment it
goes on the rampage
he's trying he's trying to stop them and
then no one's listening to my spirit
animals
i love how like they they arrest him
because he was targeting the hippies and
then they were like you don't understand
cartman this festival will bring a lot
of money for us and he goes
don't have money
yeah but that's how that's how i
described chazz and like literally
it was it was so surreal seeing because
like again talking about
we saw racial segregation uh
in that and it was just like but it was
being done
like with the right intentions in the
right way so therefore it was allowed
and it was just so weird and
one of the really funny things about
that well one they had a sign that said
uh social distancing is anti-racism
what it's like anti-racist which is like
hot huh i'm going to be confused by what
which which by the way they were very
racist because there was not a lot of
social distancing at the height of when
like a lot of people were so apparently
they were all being racist
but but then on top of that they had a
garden plot in their little chat and
they killed black children
they shot him yeah they they for ten
minutes
ten that's what i read ten minutes where
they were just unloading
what was the size of their magazines and
how many were they carrying no idea and
this was
were they firing five five six i believe
it was five five six i don't know that
exactly that's a thousand dollars these
days though
so they're rich yeah they're rich yeah
they have a lot of money if they're
gonna pop up
it's it's like that back then is
probably a lot cheaper but
still expensive it was so pretty because
it had the the corona
uh jump sail yeah you're right before
the riot gun owners yes
but just think about this for a second
there was a white suv with two black
teenagers
and it was just apparently some kids
joyriding these these
security guards who are you know they
call themselves walking around with with
rifles
panicked when they heard they saw a
vehicle and someone said it was white
supremacists
so they just started unloading i read
one article that said hundreds of rounds
for about 10 minutes just just firing in
this vehicle
i'm wondering like 10 minutes how many
magazines were they carrying wow
because if they were just unloading like
boom boom boom like i'm not saying
they're gonna like bump fire or go boom
boom boom as fast as they can
if they were all unloading they had to
be carrying what multiple 60 round mags
or something
well it was it was it was just absurd
seeing it all happen and really then
they raided the vehicle and stole
evidence and stripped it and took off
and the cops couldn't get in yeah the
cops they couldn't even rescue the kids
emts couldn't get in it it's just it's
just so
unfortunate just how what happens when
because that was only allowed to happen
because the seattle mayor and the city
council were just like
we'll just have a summer of love and
we'll we'll try to play but
try to placate that and it's just like
no like i i was there the first night
and i could already tell like this is
going to
end but this is going to end in a very
very bad way yeah a 16 year old
black child was killed a 14 year old was
left in critical condition
after being shot and this is supposed to
be a safe haven for minorities and it's
just like no
that that's just not that's not the case
and then they want all these fencing
and these barriers up because they
wanted to keep out white supremacists
it's like right because seattle i mean
seattle is very white i'll give them
that but it was just
it's just just again the mindset that
these people operate in
and they think nothing they see no irony
and the fact that the people that died
in jazz were
were african-americans how could you
tell right away that it was gonna go bad
uh so i met raz simone he was the kind
of the first warlord
uh in that but really it was just it was
because so that first night he was
harassing people for
for graffitiing on the the buildings and
there was graffiti
i mean that was one thing it was
graffiti everywhere so it's not like he
was the only person doing that
but he was harassing him i was
threatening him and then there was a
punch thrown
and so that was problem number one
problem number two was when this was the
second night where there was this group
of
basically self-declared vigilantes armed
with baseball bats
and they surrounded this one kid who and
they were accusing him of stealing a
cell phone
from one of like like from like a street
medic and the kids saying no i didn't
steal it i didn't do this and they're
like well why'd you run away from us
and they're saying and and then one of
the guys he shoved the baseball bat in
his face and he's like if you
if you keep this up i'm gonna beat your
ass beat you up
and it was just uh it was going bad
quick it was going bad really quick and
then he was if
he was able to escape from the group and
they started chasing after him
and then they realized oh he didn't act
they found the phone somewhere else he
didn't actually he didn't steal the
phone
so that was literally the second night
uh when when all this
and so i just knew it was gonna i know
that there was like some more
crimes because there was a it was kind
of like occupy wall street with all the
tents
right and kind of the crimes that
happened within the tents it was
literally almost the exact same thing
and i just knew it was going to escalate
further and further because again
it was just a free-for-all and i mean
there was there was different
groups in at different i mean the safest
part was
during the day because as typically
these things go right it's generally
safe
when it's daytime but then when it
became night it was just kind of
who had the most kind of power whether
it's through numbers or
through weapons yeah and so it just
and i'm curious it just it just resulted
it just ended in tears and
people got people got hurt and people
got killed and it didn't need to happen
yeah i wonder what we can expect in you
know in this kind of area in the coming
years i mean joe biden brought back the
migrant child facilities
i can't imagine antibodies going to be
like we're cool no they're going to go
nuts they were protesting in rochester
just the other day
and and i was in i was in portland on
inauguration day and they attacked and i
was i got video of them attacking the
the democratic headquarters in in
portland and it was just
they they they just they just hate
everybody i mean they're anti-american i
mean these these definitely
i mean so it doesn't it doesn't matter
who who really is in office they
they just kind of see it as an excuse to
do that but right yeah they're not
it's just really weird it's just i just
don't understand why democrats
you know you had jerry and adler say oh
the portland riots being done by antifa
was a myth
she's like they hate you too like they
don't want them to be to come to beat
him up and go to his office
well he cnn's offices and uh
raised the ruckus to say the least yeah
oh yeah in atlanta yeah no it was so
it's just
like i like these people are not your
friends i mean sure like they might vote
for you begrudgingly because it was
better than trump but
i mean they're they're we'll just attack
you just as easily as they will attack
any conservative or republican yeah yeah
all right well that being said let's
jump over to super chats my friends
if you haven't already smash that like
button subscribe hit the notification
bell because it really really does help
share the podcast if you really like it
leave us a good review on itunes or
spotify
or whatever it's the only real way to
grow i mean we're not going to spend
money we don't have like marketing or
anything like that but go to timcast.com
become a member and get access to
exclusive bonus episodes we just did
with mike cernovich
on the epstein files and it is kind of a
crazy story like what we talk about it's
kind of
creepy stuff because there's something
deep beneath the surface that's never
been uncovered about what's going on
with that guy
we got an episode up at timcast.com but
let's read some of these super chats
we got a super chat here fortunately i
don't think youtube for some reason
blocks
the name of the first person let me see
if i can try and read it i can't they
said
hey tim can you give a shout out to wall
street bets and remind them to hold the
effing line
we need to make our wives boyfriends
proud when we make it to the moon with
amc and gamestop stocks all right
there you go gamestop jumped what like
30 percent
jumped up against 100 and did you see
100
i read that do you see robin hood say
we're gonna make some upgrades tomorrow
so there might be some disruptions
it's just like i heard there's already
disruptions according to the carter ring
they already stopped trading in some
instances
oh my gosh i'm not going to buy any of
these i'm not going to buy the amc or
the gamestop stuff but people can buy
whatever they want i am not a financial
advisor we always say that
but if people want to buy that stuff you
know you do your thing a lot of people
bought in when it was really high
because they're like we're gonna keep
buying and then it dropped
and now they're holding the bag and
that's probably why it's gonna go back
up again because
dude if i bought in a stock at like 300
bucks and it dropped to 90. i just keep
it
yeah you can just i just keep that big
whatever i bought it you know
i'm not going to lose it i guess you
only lose the money when you sell
i don't know if it's going to go back up
to 300 bucks but you know
alessio de monte says did anyone hear
what the demos are trying to do with the
u.s nuclear arsenal what are they trying
to launch it i don't know
no well keep eric's wall wall away from
it yeah definitely
ian reichard says hi libertarian
computer scientist and fan of your work
saw your episode earlier about wanting
to build up new social media and i'm so
upset with the current state of things
and want to help let me know if i can
help in any way
send an email over to jobs at
timcast.com and we'll go through pitches
and
and you know ideas and stuff and yeah
i'm talking with
some devs about creating open source
tools
that people can use to get the core
functionality of some of the biggest
big tech companies so like live
streaming functionality super chat
functionality
tweet like micro blogging stuff sharing
groups that way it's like your website
your deal
and they can network between each other
so we'll see how that stuff works out
dylan helm says every dollar in the chat
netted you a dollar before the live show
out of the hundreds of people i only got
10 oh well it was fun i'm not quite sure
what you mean by that
never summer 160 says julio get mattis's
drinking buddy here
glad to see you finally made it to the
top tc irl
semper fi there you go
uh zapatochani i'm probably pronouncing
your name wrong tim please get adam
curry on the show to talk about
his decentralized social media we will
we will we will absolutely
mr slytrip says how do you feel about
jenk yuger naming his podcast after the
group that committed the armenian
genocide
i have said i mean based on his own
ideology should change the name should
have changed it a long time ago yeah
the young turks is a really messed up
name no joke
i understand they're trying like they're
claiming that the young turks is just a
reference to like young
upstarts who are challenging the system
sure but it's literally a reference to
it's it's the same title right it's the
same thing as these
group of people imagine if imagine if
they started uh
a a podcast network called the hitler
youth and they're like oh but we don't
actually
you know like what they said but it's
like i don't i don't
i don't care dude i went to politicon
just changing and there were people
there were armenians protesting
the young turks based and they were
saying like dude we don't hate you
we just think you should change the name
and you can even change it a little bit
and and he won't do it that to me is
weird listen i don't i don't care if he
changes his name or not
i'm saying if he's going to be true to
progressive principles and you've got
people protesting saying it's like
really messed up
how are you like going to tell
marginalized people to shove off
that's weird look into enverpasha he was
the head of the young turks
in turkey that established the army in
the genocide
man not cool tammy says tim re-diabetes
please distinguish between type 1 and
type 2.
type 2 can be avoided through healthy
lifestyle choices type 1 is lifelong
autoimmune disease
virus attacks pancreas insulin needed
lifelong that's true
i have read evidence that fasting can
help reverse the symptoms of type 1 as
well
i would i would suggest reading into it
i would i would also suggest reading
into
for people with uh type 2 ketosis yes i
don't know a lot about it
i've only read certain like medical
websites
that's why i say read it because i know
there's a lot of fad dieting around keto
people don't know what keto actually is
but look at this stuff
because i knew a guy whose kid had
epilepsy
and he got put on a ketogenic diet cured
it right up
so they tried everything all these
medications and he said the doctor
told them have your kid on a ketogenic
diet and then that was it no more
seizures
yes for whatever reason keto was used to
control epilepsy in children and it was
also used by believe the navy seals to
train their divers
there's a condition called diabetic
ketoacidosis that is very bad you do not
want that at all so watch out watch your
blood sugar
word agion rts gaming says be advised
gme stock is going up well you know if
if if people want to buy it they like
the stock they should but you should
recognize you know what was going on
with that news
mr brownstone says luke is my meme lord
and t hustla
watched grace state and good to see your
contribution to documentary good times
there's a big story behind that uh crazy
story behind that to say the least
but i don't know if they actually went
forward with the movie or not i think
they did in some ways i have to
check in on it it's been a long time oh
ian hall says sharing my gamestop
attendees with lydia's cat and luke's
worthless puppy diamond hands
rocket to the moon i'm up 20k today
he says whoopi worthless puppy i can't
believe
uh atlas is so big yeah it's only been a
few weeks
the second year flopped up oh she's
great second year
i'm going to make a post soon about it
on instagram that's a huge moment
and the german shepherd have the second
year
it's a milestone she's great lamont
cranston the fourth says ban assault
cutlery
they're doing that in the uk yes they
are actually like actually yes
yes el diablo el diablo says
what the wtf luke doesn't like polls
wtf oh oh luke doesn't like polls
this poll never lies oh yeah sean rufus
said
jim doc i might have raised one first he
says i got hairy legs
shut it's a biden quote my deal yeah
sean rufus says i'd like to support
luke but jason blocked me from
commenting as i commented jason was a
crazy conspiracy nut
thought you didn't block people luke
jason i don't block people
um um you reached out to me on
twitter lukeweirdchange uh and let me
know your username and i'll make sure
you're
not blocked i'm you
hunting club says luke reminds me of
bartender from boondock saints
semper fidelis to julio keep it the
great work everyone right you're looking
them up now
i remember uh well i'll just read some
more uh mhs kelly osbourne may have said
that but i think the tweet you are
looking for was from amber heard
yes that one she was the one who was
like protect your gardener your
protector gardeners and your mates
yes yes thank you for for these are the
worst people oh
absolutely yeah that's that's what i was
saying like they don't really care they
only
care that when it affects them
personally yeah
adam guynes jines guinness i don't
pronounce it right
politics is downstream of culture but
culture is downstream of media
people jump but the establishment still
steers the ship msm has to go
i think it's i think it's happening whoa
newtonian says check the m1 money supply
it's about to hit 20 trillion
oh no i'm gonna buy bitcoin you know
like bitcoin went down and everyone's
like i saw the media saying oh no but
bitcoin's going down i'm like oh thank
god it's going down i can buy more now
oh man but every time it goes up it's
crazy because like i remember when i hit
200 bucks i'm like oh i can't buy now
it's at 200
then it went to a thousand and i was
like i should have bought it two hundred
i remember looking at it when it was
like
a thousand i'm like ah i can't do this
this is a lot of money
yeah but what about what about dogecoin
yeah i'm not going nearly
i couldn't find my computer where i had
my old doge wallet
and i know i had some deutsch on there
and and
back in the day listen back back in the
day in november what bitcoin was 13 000
yeah so it's like up three and a half
times or whatever you put a thousand
bucks you'd have three thousand five
hundred man
crazy and and now and but i went to 56k
it's going to go back up it's keeping
going it's keep going it's going to keep
going up
because more and more corporations are
are putting some of their balance sheets
on on bitcoin
especially with the mass printing of us
dollars
you know what's really funny is i was
reading something from peter schiff and
man that guy really hates bitcoin
and he was like okay so even if i did
buy in now what's my exit strategy and i
saw one person say what's your gold exit
strategy
like people buy gold to not sell it it's
a store of value you don't do it you buy
it you just leave it you put your closet
so you buy bitcoin you put in cold
storage put in your class you walk away
yeah and there's other currencies meant
for
smaller transactions that have quicker
uh transactions
and smaller fees that are you know used
for cash or you know
or like a silver comparison yeah all
right we got javi j says stop telling
people to move
i run a custom plant and if one more
jack wagon asks
if i buy the whole cow can you do half
rib eyes and half
try tips i'm going to cancel my
subscription to the beanie broadcasting
network love
love what y'all do understandable i
apologize
if i can you do what half tri-tip and
half uh
yeah try tips black lion grunt says tim
walls have worked since 130
000 years ago in theo petra
and they will continue to work even when
humanity is so advanced our wall
our walls are made of energy walls are
forever yeah
the the death star was protected by a
wall did that stop the rebels from
destroying it a second time
and i didn't think so the first one
wasn't printed by a wall so hey
they learned right there's like a mary
williamson to quote we'll have a wall of
energy
acoustic vibration that's right matthew
sage says if you want to grow some
banana-like fruit and work towards the
shape you
uh you want i'll ship you some pawpaws
they grow natively in pennsylvania
we actually have papa trees yeah we do
yes we have many
we didn't find one did we no they're
just babies so they're not producing
fruit but
yeah so and i mean it's like east coast
appalachia there's pawpaws all over the
place i think right
never heard of them they're cool yeah a
lot of people i didn't until someone was
like oh hey you got paw paw trees i was
like
oh what yeah and they're like it's a
fruit you know yeah i looked up the
foliage
alexander thomas says ian is right
arabic has gender in the second person
you
also in semitic languages hebrew and
arabic male is unmarked and female is
marked
interesting dad teaches
says in russian some names like michka
can be a woman and man's nickname so the
last name makes it easy to see what
gender they are
oh interesting cool oh so you could have
michika
and with with like last name you know
ski they know it's a guy
interesting i always thought that was
those that was kind of crazy when i
heard because
like what would happen if they come to
america like do they have different last
names
yeah it's on uh it's on your documents
as wow
crazy that's neat archangel says semper
fi always good to see a fellow jar head
on tim cast irl
there you go yeah a lot of marines great
yeah everyone's stuck on it
boosted 300 says if you think the
romance languages are bad arabic is an
extremely gendered language and the
gender of nouns are determined by if it
is able to reason
oh what really
yeah some people do some things i mean
yes zach 2007 says sour patch is
beautiful
tim thoughts on sacdaf requiring
military to address extremism in the
military
great work y'all lydia you are gorgeous
well then
i'll ask uh you julio this this like
vetting they're doing of of the military
to like read out extremism what do you
think about it because we've talked
about it i mean i mean from what
i can say from my personal experience
like it is against the ucmj to be part
of
extremists i believe it's or it's a ucmj
or marine corps policy i can't remember
it's been a while but you you can't be
part of these groups and obviously you
shouldn't because
the the whole point of these units are
to be cohesive and yeah
so so so with that being said i i do
have
some of my friends who are in the active
duty side and really it's just kind of
they're they're they're just very
concerned about how yes like
we it's just under the guise of yes
extremism bad but then it's like
well what is yes extremism and we've
seen
uh on the political stage well extremism
is just simply as oh
you wear mag ahead or you're a trump
supporter
yeah xyz right or come and take it right
it's like well no that's that's not
extremism that's actually
pretty normal and so there are some
concerns and i would have some concerns
as well on on whether or not it is
legitimate to actually weed out some
extremists wherever whatever
side it is or if it's just specifically
target
yeah conservatives which would be
obviously concerning
so i'll just ask real quick uh how so
you mentioned you have active duty
friends how does it work being in the
reserves
uh so so uh the reserves is basically
you do one week in a month
you show up to drill your duty station
for your job or whatever for one week in
a month and then two weeks out of the
year
is when you then and then two weeks out
of the year you do
that instead of one weekend that
actually sounds kind of fun
it is it is nice i i enjoy it for what
it is
what's your job if you don't mind me
asking yes so i am
a zero five 11 marine corps or marine
air ground task force planning
specialist
huh mouthful what is that yeah yeah
so basically it's large-scale logistics
they say
you can't don't call it the travel agent
of a marine corps but that's
that's kind of what we are it's not it's
not a very big mos
and actually the unit that i'm attached
to uh because i enlisted out of illinois
and
when you're signing up for the reserves
you you pick your job necessarily on
your asvab score but based on what the
units are around local because you
you're going to live there
uh but so when i moved out here i kind
of assumed because that is kind of like
a
big level job i figure with all the
units out here with the pentagon like
there has to be a
a slot for me it turns out there wasn't
and so and so
the the the unit that i'm attached to
now is um a debt prp
personnel retrieval and processing so it
is the body baggers
of the marine corps and so and so
actually during the early days of the
pandemic
uh the we were on put on standby and
actually this was the closest i was to
actually being deployed
in in any sense uh because basically we
were looking at going at new york city
when they were hit very hard because
there was there was already
a national guard unit uh that would
that's their mortuary affair
and the crazy governor that was sending
well well yeah yeah
like no wonder no wonder that they
probably needed us because governor
cuomo wanted to get
the same governor who's in very hot
water and has very serious allegations
against them right now that the
mainstream
media by and large is ignoring using so
so so it's good for what it is uh
although it became
a bit of a impairment or it
yeah hamstring me a little bit in terms
of my civilian career just because
uh like i said riots were happening
almost every other week and so i knew
one so my my annual training those two
weeks uh was gonna be in july and i knew
i was gonna miss something and i was
like okay well
it's just a matter of what am i going to
miss and lo and behold portland
at the federal courthouse that was the
national story and so i missed the
beginning of it but
after as soon as i was done with
training i hopped on a flight to
portland
and so i covered that last week uh
before they finally
were able to have the oregon state
police provide the security so that they
could pull the
extra federal officers out there so i
was able to see kind of like how it was
before and after that so
it was so uh i'm not re-enlisting just
because
my civilian career has obviously taken
kind of a little bit of
upward trend and so i like having the
the freedom and flexibility of being
able to just leave at a moment's notice
to cover
whatever it is but i i very much enjoy
i'm going to miss it obviously but
it's it's great for you make it for what
it is you enlisted
yeah yeah so i'm a corporal so when when
uh when you enlist you go through like
basic training yeah
yeah so so for and this is for any
reserve
component for any so you go through the
same
initial training uh the only difference
is that as soon as i was done
once i became a mactaff planner uh
everyone else
then left for their duty station and
then i went home
and so it and so it's funny because kind
of the joke is you know
uh reservists are you know they're
weekend warriors and
stuff like that he's like so okay that's
fine you can insult me you can call me
whatever you want but when you do you
make sure you call me at home
yeah right yeah exactly and so
it's it's fine it's i i enjoy it for
what it but it's also
it's also kind of weird because when
people do find out marine like oh thank
you for your service and like i haven't
done anything and and so i don't try to
like
make you know i don't make it out more
than what it is and yeah in in
and there is a little bit of a kind of a
i don't know
inferiority complex but it's just kind
of like yeah because a lot of my
sergeants and staff are in the gunneys
that are in the reserves they were
active duty and they they've been in
some crazy like one of my
uh gunnies was in the fallujah uh
and so he he actually met mattis uh
briefly
uh during during that time but so it's
just kind of like all right yeah and
i'm a corporal now but like it doesn't i
mean i didn't do anything and
so it's it's it's kind of a weird stage
but again it you
you make it of what you make it what it
is and
and so i enjoy it for i enjoy it i like
it a lot i'm gonna miss it but i
obviously gotta focus on
what the thing that's actually making
money right so we're getting a lot of
people correcting us
about the censorship stuff they say
tipper gore was her name and she was a
democrat
so uh yeah robert says tipper girl was a
republican wow news to me
so yeah i guess i guess the reality is
it was never just the republicans it was
it was democrats and it's still
democrats there you go more
authoritarianism
like i said i don't remember i remember
i was i was barely walking
spring check elaine bennis says federal
reserve payment system crashed today
yeah did you guys see that that was
crazy like three trillion dollars in
payments did not move
they said it was like a clerical error
but they were it was kind of unclear
sure sure yeah what happened uncultured
barbarian says gta 5 and gta online are
still incredibly popular and receive
regular updates even seven years later
actually the reason gta 6 is taking so
long to come out is because they still
make insane amount of money off five
that's right yep
yeah uh i know people who have been
playing gta 5
non-stop just i mean it's a great game
it is it really really is
fun but here's the thing like do we just
rest on our laurels now or do we like
can we just
get a vr game that's like better than
ever you know
it's great that we reach this point
where the game's just so good
we stop now we gotta make even better
games we gotta make gta 10.
where you can actually feel the objects
and pick them up haptic feedback's going
to be nice
yeah mark de la russo says
question for tim and luke what books and
or digital news magazines do you
recommend
digital news magazines are those are
those a thing they are
digital news magazines yeah i mean
yeah you sure about that well i would
say jack have been for the sake of
understanding what you're what your
political rivals think i'm not a fan of
socialism but i did get a subscription
to jacobin for for one reason
their defense of free speech on more
than one occasion i respect and
i they hate the democrats so i want to
see their perspective on why they hate
the democrats it was what happened they
wrote an article saying everybody hates
the democrats and i was like yes
correct yes this is true and i wanted to
read it it was a scripture
member only but i thought you know what
i shouldn't enter looking at that
magazine as though i'm going to be
completely at odds with everything they
say
i should read it and try and figure out
what we disagree on
and why they think those things and what
we do agree on
so i mean for that matter i mean i don't
know what conservative magazine i don't
subscribe to any other magazine to be
honest
i just saw that and i was like they're
the actual non-establishment political
faction
that i typically disagree with but we
agree on a lot of things
i should probably see what they're
talking about because if there's
something they're saying about hating
democrats i'm like
i wonder where we can agree and like
go against the establishment political
class you know what i mean yeah i don't
really like
magazines but uh just to kind of answer
your question a little
bit i do like john pilger even though i
don't always agree with him
i really love his documentaries and i
think they're very thought-provoking
dr doctor tries to make a south park
reference i'll read it anyway
so you guys being into the magic the
gathering are you guys into the hardcore
[ __ ] magic scene
some pretty intense stuff from what i
hear supposedly this is one rooster
named gadnik
breaker of worlds who is undefeated
south
is great these these guys are funny they
did a really i don't i don't know why
they did an episode of magic the
gathering
but it was really funny and it didn't
make sense they make fun of me because
it was just like they
i i get it they didn't want to actually
learn the rules of the game
but it was like there were roosters
playing magic the gathering
and it was like you know [ __ ] fighting
and so the cops were involved and then
whoa yeah it was funny it was funny
that's funny
yeah a lot of people mentioning tip or
gore was this more authoritarian so
we stand corrected absolutely taper gore
was the founder of the pmrc the parental
advisory tags
luke booing at the australian open the
crowd was a the crowd allegedly was
predominantly serb and russian
because of the lurgy got the indomitable
slavs
are go i'm sorry go the indomitable
slavs there you go
they were booing that's great yeah we
like to express our opinions
i like that yeah stoned krampus says ian
constantly conflates his own mental
experience and status with everyone else
i've been watching non-horror violent
movies and playing violent video games
since i was four
i learned to shoot at four started
martial arts at five not once violent in
30 years
there you go
dj madero says tim lydia ian luke you
should read arthur c clarke's 3001
especially the sources and
acknowledgments at the back of the book
it will blow your mind the part about
vacuum energy
interesting i recently learned something
really crazy today about
uh a new communications technology that
is confidential i can't talk about
that made me say no way in the like yup
some something revolutionary on the
horizon so it's
it's like einstein level stuff i i
wonder if aliens are real
and and you know and i i the reason i
say that is because normally i'm like
it's probably military technology and
then i had a conversation earlier with a
confidential source
and i'm like i don't believe this i
don't believe the stuff they're talking
about but we saw
we covered these segments where the ufo
technology stuff the warp drive stuff
i think we're getting close to a
breakthrough in some kind of
technological component i'm not really
saying italians
but you have to imagine like at the turn
of the century of the 1800s and 1900s
you had like the invention of the
telephone coming out you had photographs
you like could you imagine what it must
have been like to have to communicate by
carrier pigeon
and then all of a sudden some dude's got
a piece of metal wire and you can hear
his voice
from the other side of the building
you'd be like whoa and then they lay the
transatlantic cable
and then all of a sudden one day you
wake up you could talk to people in
london
boom like that it's crazy i think i
think you know we're due
for some kind of major expansion of
technology it's been gradual but we'll
see
coach jay says much love irl crew
rosa speak in truth luke get new
curtains not plaid
ian couldn't seem to find uh seemed to
fit graphene into conversation yesterday
lid's on fire oh and
that's right awesome work irl oh i'm i'm
i'm a senile old
fumbling i like my plaid i would make
graphic
background when i make my videos
tovan benson says amp for life join the
empire look at the flexa network and
collateral altcoins is what is amp is
that a coin
what sounds right i did not understand
that yeah i missed all of that sorry d
blaze 25 says hey tim first time super
chatter i am an up and coming luthier
and would love to build a free guitar
for you
what i'm specializing in is video game
replica guitars
i've built a zelda zorro replica guitar
let me know dude i would love
a custom built guitar uh what's a what's
a good video game
you already said you did zelda i'm not
entirely sure what uh what video game
but uh feel free to
um i don't know the easiest way to
communicate with me is honestly
uh send an email to
which which which emails youtube spin
the ufo i check that one
spin the ufo gmail.com mention the
guitar and we'll we'll uh that'd be
awesome
because then we could actually have it
we could use it for shows and stuff yeah
cool
maybe we can get a i don't know an irl
themed guitar of some sort oh yeah
like a ufc yeah like color scheme and i
have no idea
you know i don't know like the zeppelin
the hrump zeppelin
yeah something like that it's kind of
steep punk
chris logan says julio i was in the
usmcr
too i remember my command specifically
not wanting us to get involved in
anything political
how do you get away with it in this
political environment also
boot yes i am a boot yeah boo boo hog
reservist yeah no it's just the worst of
all
um so there there are a little bit so if
you're active duty there is a little bit
there is a lot more restrictions on on
you as a person but like for example i
mean you have uh
uh senator dan sullivan from alaska he's
still he's still in the marine corps
reserves and he's a car
wow uh so basically there is a little
bit more
gabbard right tulsa gabbard yeah she was
i mean she
uh uh adam kinziger i mean he makes he's
making news all the time
right now these days but he he's still
in the air national guard so that there
are ways to
to do it uh just for me personally i
obviously
uh the main thing is i was actually
telling you guys earlier uh just don't
you can't do uh obvious uh political
endorsements of any
particular candidates yourself uh i i
guess so yeah because then
like jesse was a major in the national
guard yeah like because like yeah that's
you
yeah i mean even though she really
didn't have much of a chance
but there was that discussion like if
she did become president she would be
the commander-in-chief but
so what would happen to her her rank she
gets a promotion i guess yeah yeah
can she appoint herself as a general
that's wow as i'm saying
um but that was a little bit of
interesting discussion um and so but
yeah so i
i that's why i stick to uh when it comes
to really the hot topics that's why i
want to
cover riots and on the ground coverage
it's just it's just neutral it's just
it's just record what i see
because not only just because like i
think that's just what journalism
should be um but obviously when
you know when you have all these
detractors and
all these people in the media that want
to discredit your work you don't want to
give them an excuse because they say oh
well he's an audio log he's just there
and you're like yes i work for a
conservative website but i specifically
make it a point to do just neutral
coverage and and
and really that's what because that's
what people want number one and so i'm
serving the readers
and also too when it comes to those
types of events i don't need to inject
my opinion
as it's happening now i do provide like
analysis and opinion
after the fact after i've had time to
actually like digest what i've seen what
i report on and that really came in
handy with the written house shooting
because i saw the second half of that
yeah
and i didn't and you know at the time i
had no idea like what this guy did or
like i didn't know the context of like
what led to the first set of shootings
uh because i'm really good friends with
richie and he was he was there i don't
know you guys you guys had him on yeah
of course
with that so that really came in handy
because then uh
when i was able to look further into the
evidence and seeing that i could
have a bigger picture so then when i was
interviewed i can give a clearer
uh image on like what i saw and like
what my friend saw and so it's just
it's it's just very important in my view
to to have it that way now i do have
opinions i do have facts but i make sure
i kind of fall within the line of
the regulations could i have a question
i don't know if you know the answer to
can the president
choose any does he appoint generals he
does right yeah he does nominations yeah
so he he nominates and then they get
confirmed excuse me well they kind of go
through it well
i'm not entirely sure if but like they
he he does
he does appoint generals i'm wondering
if could he like just pick a random
person
do they have to be in the armed forces
or something well yeah they would have
to be
because so they're the
commander-in-chief you know but they
have to be in the military
well i was thinking this because i was
uh you know i saw this tweet from jack
bosovic about kashmir pulaski
who was like this amazing dude and
people from chicago know the name
pulaski it's like the name of one of our
biggest streets and we got
train stations named after him and he
founded the american revolutionary
cavalry
came from poland i think it was like the
polish lithuanian commodore at the time
i'm not sure
and then they like lost some conflict
and then he came here and aided the
americans and he's honored
he's one of only eight people who are
honorary american citizens he was
awarded posthumous
posthumously but i think about the
american revolution and there were many
circumstances where somebody
was just given a commission like some
ranking officer was like congratulations
sir you now have rank over all these men
yeah it's like does that happen in the
modern military where like
yeah i didn't think so no no yeah no
that was back in the olden days
yeah it was if anything goes back now
it's like if you want to not now they'll
just contract someone but you can't have
any command or anything like that right
or how would that work
what do you mean like so let's say they
hire a private military contractor oh a
contract oh okay
yeah so like you know what does
blackwater call these days aegis or
academy or disease well let's say you've
got paramilitaries
hired by the us government and they're
operating in say iraq
and there are american military units
also
in a similar position how does that work
you know does the contractor who's being
paid by the government to
complete a task are they able to tell
the american you know
combat you know infantry whatever to
back off or to move in or anything like
that
i don't know if you know the answer no
no that i don't know like i said i
haven't deployed or haven't had to deal
with any of that i'm sure someone else
could
can provide some more context i'm sure
there's like rules engagement and
chain of command stuff but i mean that i
i just don't have experience in that
word
all right we got kristen larson says
matt larson
quote the father of modern combatives is
awesome and you try to have him on your
show the left tried to cancel him
your name is kristen larsen and you're
promoting someone named matt larson are
you related to this individual
trying to promote that conflict of
interest yeah all right let's see
politically defiant says tim in your 10
a.m video you spoke of trump and musk
questioning why they themselves don't
create a social net social network
banking along with digital and physical
infrastructure required to be free of
big tech
answer is simple they themselves are
insulated you know
daedalus 62 says adam gave his rib for
eve
when they come together to uh they
become one they complete each other
interesting very nice well let's uh
let's let's just read one more super
chat here
well we're going to read two because
someone just for some reason nom ba
says chrono trigger oh oh chrono trigger
for a guitar that's a cool cool one
chrono trigger is one of the best games
ever made
i don't know if i'd be super into it but
i i maybe it's a good game
yeah uh el ca za waruto says tim
what's your favorite anime slash manga i
love when you talk about one punch man
and no one else knew what you were
talking about
but i can appreciate a man of culture
have you watched jojo's bizarre
adventure i haven't but man have i seen
the memes
my favorite anime manga man i don't know
none
that's tough you said you guys say none
no mega
oh no no no anime no anime no no no no
you guys you guys aren't cultured and
refined i mean i appreciate
it i mean elon musk posted pictures of
anime cat girls don't care
that's weird i like that that's weird
that's a little weird
i liked uh what was the one about were
they going to the video game
they go into there's a bunch it's a
bunch there's a ton of them
yeah it is it's like they're going into
the video online yeah any idea
i like that narrows it down i like sword
art in the first season but then it just
got repetitive i thought
i uh was a big fan for a really long
time of bleach and naruto but those are
obvious
picks those are like the top tier anime
i i never watched there wasn't
technically pokemon anime too
yeah and when i was a kid i really liked
it but man was that show not good
like wow that's just like i look back
i'm like what is it about this where i
was excited to watch it i was a little
kid
song pokemon yeah that's right i'll
admit the theme song good
yeah right right now there's a couple
that are really well black clover is
really good and
uh so what about the doctor or they're
going around making dr stone yeah
it's cool um my hero academia is
probably my favorite right now that was
good yeah but i don't really keep up
with a lot of these shows as much as i
used to when i was younger because i
don't really watch tv anymore what would
you pick if you had to pick one
right now if i was gonna turn on
crunchyroll if you're gonna be like for
all the humans to come here let me throw
one at you guys so you have it forever
ah if i had to like give someone
historical anime to watch
i have no idea man dragon ball the whole
dragon ball
i mean just because it's the classic and
it lay the foundation for a lot of these
elements
you you hakusho probably i would i would
i would say that if i was telling
someone like
i would say watch you hakko show for
sure but i would say right now if i was
going to turn on crunchyroll and watch
anime it would probably be
my hero academia um maybe
i don't know there's another one i can't
remember what it's called but that you
know black clover and probably my hair
academia they're very similar maybe you
want to watch dragon ball
it's just classic the original dragon
ball then dragon ball z
are just like the the classic elements
of a lot of
the anime that you know that are now
really popular these days so i thought
um
cowboy bebop's pretty spectacular oh man
i can't believe i missed the music
especially
definitely there's just so much about it
if if i had to tell someone like the one
anime you had to watch for like the
historical record if i was going to put
on a golden disc and blast up and out of
space cobb would be
really that would be it over dragon ball
oh definitely really
well if you want to explain like anime
tropes
you want to do dragon ball but if you
want to show like the best
people like people like luke he's got
this look on his face he's like the main
guy
i've spaced out for the past five
minutes cowboy bebop
is about it's like sci-fi bounty hunters
and the main character is like he knows
jeet kune do and he's a big fan of bruce
lee and it's like gangster
it's like like almost 1930s style
gangster but in sci-fi space
it is one of the best firefly you ever
see that movie it's kind of like yeah
and and the jazz music is just
incredible stuff i'll leave it at that
we're going to go over to thetimcast.com
exclusive members only segment coming up
so make sure you check that out you can
follow me on all the social media
platforms at tim cast
my other channels are youtube.com
timcast youtube.comcastnews
please like share subscribe to this
channel we are so close to 1 million
subscribers
so help spread the word so we can get
another one of those fancy gold medals
and rub it in the face of all the people
who don't like the politics we talk
about but uh leave us a good review if
you're listening on the podca on podcast
platforms and of course share this
but uh uh julio is anything you want to
mention yeah no i mean so
if you appreciate the work that i do for
town hall you can become a vip
subscriber
uh because that money not only saved us
uh during the chronovirus
uh lockdowns and all that but that money
goes towards funding for all the trips
that i do
and get exclusive access to to the
articles that on my travels as well so
right now very cool townhall.com
so right now i am meeming up a storm on
luke we are chains on instagram
the shirt i'm wearing right now is also
my representation of our society and it
has
the hunger games animal animal farm they
live brave new world matrix fahrenheit
451 v for vendetta and of course
1984 representing where i think we are
and if you like the shirt and want it
and want to support my
independent media efforts you can on
thebestpoliticalshirts.com don't forget
to check me out on youtube
we are changed as well thanks for having
me and you can follow me pretty much all
over the internet ian crossland and hit
up my website at ian crossland.net
you can follow you can find a lot of my
socials from there and if you want to
buy a mug
or um maybe a cool mouse pad you can
support my work by going to my
my merchandise always leave a donation
if you'd like but i really appreciate
you guys i love you very much
very cool and you guys it would mean the
world to me if we hit a million that was
all i wanted for christmas we didn't
reach it by christmas but i'm hoping by
this spring we will i am sour patch lids
on twitter
i'm also on mines i'm real sour patch
lids on gab
and instagram so follow me there you
guys on clubhouse
no no not that cool i don't even i don't
have an iphone or not oh that's what i
forgot i forgot if you invite me
i will be you have an iphone luke yeah
it's only invite only yeah
are you willing to base your reputation
on me no
i just met you yeah that's fair to say
here all right all right i'm a person of
color
don't you discriminate against me all
right
ladies and gentlemen go over to
timcast.com check out the exclusive
members only segment which will be
coming up in just about an hour or so
maybe a little longer sometimes we just
really get into it we do a full bonus
episode
but we'll see you all then thanks for
hanging out bye guys
you